[Music]
deep learning has become the most
debated technology of the 21st century
it has found a wide range of
applications in various sectors of
business such as healthcare finance
manufacturing
entertainment logistics and lots more
companies are using deep learning for
building predictive models there are
multiple frameworks available that make
deep learning easy to implement the most
popular among them is tensorflow hi guys
welcome to this complete tensorflow
tutorial by simplylearn and today we
will be covering all the essential
topics of deep learning and tensorflow
we will first understand what is deep
learning and look at the various
applications of deep learning then we
will see the different deep learning
frameworks available and learn how to
install tensorflow on ubuntu we will
implement deep learning with python
understand what is tensorflow tensorflow
tutorial and carry out object detection
using tensorflow api let's first look at
a small animated video to understand
deep learning in five minutes
ever wondered how google translates an
entire web page to a different language
in a matter of seconds or your phone
gallery group's images based on their
location all of this is a product of
deep learning but what exactly is deep
learning deep learning is a subset of
machine learning which in turn is a
subset of artificial intelligence
artificial intelligence is a technique
that enables a machine to mimic human
behavior machine learning is a technique
to achieve ai through algorithms trained
with data and finally deep learning is a
type of machine learning inspired by the
structure of the human brain in terms of
deep learning this structure is called
an artificial neural network let's
understand deep learning better and how
it's different from machine learning say
we create a machine that could
differentiate between tomatoes and
cherries if done using machine learning
we'd have to tell the machine the
features based on which the two can be
differentiated these features could be
the size and the type of stem on them
with deep learning on the other hand the
features are picked out by the neural
network without human intervention of
course that kind of independence comes
at the cost of having a much higher
volume of data to train our machine
now let's dive into the working of
neural networks
here we have three students each of them
write down the digit nine on a piece of
paper
notably they don't all write it
identically the human brain can easily
recognize the digits
but what if a computer had to recognize
them
that's where deep learning comes in
here's a neural network trained to
identify handwritten digits
each number is present as an image of 28
times 28 pixels now that amounts to a
total of 784 pixels
neurons the core entity of a neural
network is where the information
processing takes place
each of the 784 pixels is fed to a
neuron in the first layer of our neural
network
this forms the input layer
on the other end we have the output
layer with each neuron representing a
digit with the hidden layers existing
between them
the information is transferred from one
layer to another over connecting
channels
each of these has a value attached to it
and hence is called a weighted channel
all neurons have a unique number
associated with it called bias
this bias is added to the weighted sum
of inputs reaching the neuron
which is then applied to a function
known as the activation function
the result of the activation function
determines if the neuron gets activated
every activated neuron passes on
information to the following layers
this continues until the second last
layer
the one neuron activated in the output
layer corresponds to the input digit the
weights and bias are continuously
adjusted to produce a well-trained
network so where is deep learning
applied in customer support when most
people converse with customer support
agents the conversation seems so real
they don't even realize that it's
actually a bot on the other side in
medical care neural networks detect
cancer cells and analyze mri images to
give detailed results self-driving cars
what seem like science fiction is now a
reality apple tesla and nissan are only
a few of the companies working on
self-driving cars so deep learning has a
vast scope but it too faces some
limitations the first as we discussed
earlier is data while deep learning is
the most efficient way to deal with
unstructured data a neural network
requires a massive volume of data to
train let's assume we always have access
to the necessary amount of data
processing this is not within the
capability of every machine and that
brings us to our second limitation
computational power training a neural
network requires graphical processing
units which have thousands of cores as
compared to cpus and gpus are of course
more expensive and finally we come down
to training time deep neural networks
take hours or even months to train the
time increases with the amount of data
and number of layers in the network so
here's a short quiz for you arrange the
following statements in order to
describe the working of a neural network
a the bias is added b the weighted sum
of the inputs is calculated c specific
neuron is activated d the result is fed
to an activation function leave your
answers in the comments section below
some of the popular deep learning
frameworks include tensorflow pytorch
keras deep learning 4j cafe and
microsoft cognitive toolkit considering
the future predictions for deep learning
and ai we seem to have only scratched
the surface in fact horus technology is
working on a device for the blind that
uses deep learning with computer vision
to describe the world to the users
replicating the human mind at the
entirety may be not just an episode of
science fiction for too long the future
is indeed full of surprises and that is
deep learning for you in short i hope
this has got you excited to learn more
about deep learning and tensorflow now
we have richard and mohan who will take
you through the journey of learning deep
learning and tensorflow in detail with
that over to you richard deep learning
applications by simply learn my name is
richard kirschner with the simply learn
team that's
www.simplylearn.com get certified get
ahead in today's exciting world of ai
artificial intelligence we're going to
cover some of the many uses it's being
applied to healthcare entertainment
composing music image coloring robotics
image captioning advertising earthquake
prediction and there's many more it's
just an exciting time to be in the field
of ai and deep learning and artificial
intelligence now all these fields are
just booming it's just amazing what's
going on so let's take a quick glance at
some of the things going on and we'll
start with our healthcare we take a look
at healthcare deep learning is reshaping
healthcare industry by delivering new
possibilities to improve people's lives
and we have computer-aided disease
detection i know a number of startups
have come up where they're working on
you take a picture like if you have some
kind of irritation or rash and they use
that or even you know some infection in
the eye and they use the deep learning
to help identify what it is hey this is
99.99
nothing don't worry about it or this is
93 chance um it usually doesn't come out
93 chance if you do deep learning but it
says hey you should probably take this
into the doctor you know have them take
a look at it and see what it is these
are the things it could be analyzing
genomes that's a big one very
controversial nowadays with all the
different genome editing and options
they have and things they're doing but
deep learning is definitely diving into
the genome projects we have discovering
new drugs and this there's so many
directions for new drugs going on it's
like one of the booming industries
especially in the us but all across the
world and they range from exploring
different plants and the opening up of
let's say marijuana in the us a number
of cities are exploring that for medical
use to how do you reprogram t cells in
the human body to combat disease there's
whole industries in data analysis
another one is chemistry how do you use
a chemical cell or a chemistry molecule
not cell a chemical molecule to imitate
the t cell so you can then put those
molecules in there and then they grab
the disease cells out or the cancer
cells or whatever out just like the
human body would so discovering new
drugs and how to apply that is just a
huge industry all these are huge
industries and medical imaging we'll
even take a glance closer at that but
being able to analyze you know you get
your mri you get your cat scans the
doctors can spend a long time looking at
those and taking careful measurements
and most of that's done by hand but as
we start applying deep learning the deep
learning can do a lot of that work not
only do it the same but it'll be uniform
from one hospital to the next meaning
that as a industry it continues to
progress and you get better results and
better services so deep learning is
reshaping healthcare industry by
delivering new possibilities to improve
people's life and deep learning helps in
early detection of cancer cells and
tumors improves a time consuming process
of synthesizing new drugs and inverse
sophisticated medical instruments and
not even sophisticated they're using
iphones and deep learning to help with
medical diagnosis so it's at all levels
it's just amazing what they're doing in
the healthcare industry with deep
learning and they've just barely tapped
what there's possible they're just now
evolving into the beginning of this
where it's exploding out there so
entertainment uh that's always a fun one
a lot of people go into the
entertainment and deep learning because
it's just fun you know what's my
favorite movie
all that fun stuff deep learning is used
in the entertainment industry such as
netflix amazon and film making and you
have like your recommendations that's
probably the most common one you see and
you can see here where they have uh
india transform the true story the third
pillar now markets in the state leave so
it comes up and says hey this is based
on whoever and of course this is showing
up on amazon or amazon prime netflix
does a good job of grouping movies for
you and says since you like these movies
you might like these movies over here
same thing with vivo it does that also
amazon netflix and vivo use recommender
systems to provide personalized
experience to its viewers using their
show preferences time of access history
etc so really this is one of the cool
things is instead of having to dig for
the information deep learning starts
doing that for you so instead of
spending hours trying to figure out what
you want to watch you can actually just
enjoy the movies and have them come up
deep learning is used in the
entertainment industry such as netflix
amazon and filmmaking continue on in
deep learning we have things like the
ibm watson this is just really cool i
didn't know this until i read this until
we did this slide wimbledon 2018 used
ibm watson to analyze player emotions
and expressions through hundreds of
hours of footage then it auto generated
highlights for the telecast so you can
imagine somebody sitting there looking
through all the boring stuff i want to
look at the interesting stuff it helps
us sort that out again you know just
like the netflix and referral it helps
you find your choices without having to
do all the heavy work of digging through
really bad b rated movies and music and
audio generation another huge part of
the industry and this kind of blends
right in with video and movie making
voice and audio recognition technology
can be used to train deep learning
network to produce music compositions so
it learns the patterns and generates new
music google's wavenet and beidou's deep
speech can train a computer to learn the
patterns and the statistics that are
unique to the music it can then generate
a complete new composition that's a
little scary i always thought that
creativity would always be the human
factor that we'd always have our
creativity but you know computers can do
some of that too and then we have our
reed's lip movements oxford and google
scientists created a neural network
called lipnet that could read people's
lips with 93 success this can be used to
add sounds to silent movies i like that
it'd be fun to hear what they actually
were saying back there they probably
said something totally different than
what's actually on the movie that'd be
pretty funny on the scary note this
would allow surveillance equipment to
pull what people are saying even if
they're really far away as long as they
can see the lips that's a little scary
coloring images and videos deep learning
can be used to color images and videos
by taking the objects in their context
within the photograph so you have your
black and white images fed in and you
have a convolutional neural network is
used to learn the patterns and usually
you train it you train it with hundreds
of black and white photos that you
already have the color image for so you
know what to expect and you take the new
one and it recreates the image by adding
the colors and this is also used in the
movie industry to add in special effects
there's all kinds of cool things they
can do with this it goes way beyond just
coloring pictures of course the coloring
pictures is something that you can
probably do in your own lab on your own
computer and build your own neural
network to do that robotics one of my
favorites robotics all these tools that
make them so exciting is that you can go
out and
even now used to be you'd have to spend
four five six ten thousand us dollars to
buy your own robot and then start
programming it and doing neural networks
now it's around two thousand dollars and
that continues to plummet uh there's
even kid robots much cheaper robotic
hands all of that that you can purchase
and generate your own neural network and
start trying to figure out how to get it
to do things and so we talk about deep
learning it's heavily used these days in
building robots to perform human-like
tasks robots are built to understand the
world around them very important how to
figure out what's what i remember if you
go back 20 years they could not get a
robot to figure out the difference
between a coke can and a pencil because
they're both cylinders and he just they
just had no idea how to do that back
then you know they did the beginning of
robotics really the neural networks was
mid 90s where it started really taking
off and the theory started coming in and
so you go back to that time and figuring
out those differences was almost
impossible before then and they trained
to make better and safer decisions
without supervision uh and you can see
in this case you know in outer space
having a robot up there uh you know if
the window blows out air pressure's lost
the robot is you know not going to be
hurt by it because they don't need air
and oxygen and their decisions usually
instead of being like a human's tired in
this case the robot never is tired so
you know there's definitely a lot of
tasks for a robot that can be used to
replace humans would be safer think uh
nuclear reactors that melted down after
the tsunami in japan using robotics to
go in there and clean up would be really
important instead of putting a person in
a hazmat suit that might or might not
protect him from the radiation in boston
dynamics we have uh spot mini he's fun
to watch if we pull up the video or the
atlas robots by boston dynamics react to
people pushing them around get up when
they fall can unload a dishwasher and do
other tasks as well so we're starting to
see this kind of robotics coming into
the house the atlas obviously is a very
expensive robot but there is certainly
more common ones you can actually bring
into the house and then spot mini is fun
to watch run you can i forget how fast
he goes but he goes pretty fast image
caption generation another part of the
industry in deep learning deep learning
is used to display the contents of an
image i love this with my google photos
the system is trained with very large
convolutional neural networks for
detecting objects in the photographs and
then a recurring neural network like an
lstm is used to turn the labels into
coherent sentence dog catching a ball so
this is awesome this is like you go into
your google photos and you say hey i
want all the pictures of my dog or i
want all the pictures of kids or
whatever it is and they get to the point
where you can now do i want pictures
where my dog is catching the ball
advertising one of the better paid
fields in ai is in marketing and
advertising especially if you are
working on bonuses and commissions so
advertising and advertising deep
learning allows optimizing a user's
experience so deep learning helps
publishers and advertisers to increase
the relevancy of the ads and boosts the
advertising campaigns allows a network
to reduce cost by dropping the cost per
acquisition of a campaign from 60 to 30
dollars create data-driven predictive
advertising real-time bidding of their
ads and target display advertising and
again this goes uh from experimental
where i'm just gonna guess what people
want and we'll put out a pink sign that
says um you want to add on widget to
your order well nobody wants widgets and
nobody wants to see the pink sign maybe
you got three people want to see the
pink sign and you find out that the blue
sign a lot of people are reading that
and they really want a widget number two
whatever that is uh so when you talk
about advertising it also deals with
marketing and also preference of
merchandise so it becomes really huge as
far as what you're advertising and
generating profit and sales for a
company and that's across the board
whether you're talking big real estate
or
property management and rentals or
amazon uses this for all their
merchandise coming out of their
warehouses any of those are generated
from the ai generates more sales and
that's the bottom dollar business is
always looking at the bottom dollar
where can i make money on this
earthquake prediction so now we're
getting to something uh safety human
safety you can also think weather
predictions all those fun things deep
learning model can be used to predict
earthquakes by considering a factor
called von mice's yield criterion
scientists at harvard use deep learning
to teach a computer perform viscoelastic
computations that is quite the mouthful
which are used in prediction of
earthquakes this application helped to
improve the earthquake calculation by 50
000 percent that's amazing we went from
just guessing when an earthquake is
going to happen where we have almost no
reliability to being able to have a
decent gas as when the earthquakes are
going to hit that's pretty impressive
let's cover some of the big players in
deep learning today and deep learning is
just so exciting this is the forefront
of our machine learning and artificial
intelligence and where it's at as far as
the cutting edge and what's coming next
that doesn't mean ignore all the machine
learning tools because certainly they've
been around a long time and are a basis
for a lot of deep learning platforms
along with solving the more basic
problems but deep learning is the
cutting edge it is the one that's
finding new solutions to things we never
thought were solvable before and today
we're going to look at uh just a quick
look at tensorflow probably the biggest
package out there right now keras which
is probably one of the biggest growing
packages out there right now pie torch
theano dl4j cafe chainer and the cntk
now all these packages center on deep
learning and neural networks if you
haven't studied our neural networks and
how they function send a note down below
in the youtube video and we'll post some
more information or one of our other
videos just so you have an idea what
deep learning is but let's go ahead and
dive in let's take a look at tensorflow
and as we look at these things i want
you also to notice that a lot of this
overlaps you'll see companies are
investing in all of these different
products to see where they go so these
are all huge players no matter where
you're coming from so let's look at
tensorflow tensorflow was developed by
google brain team it supports languages
both python and r that's a big you'll
see python is probably one of the
biggest players in the data science
neural networks across all the packages
that doesn't discount in the other ones
and certainly a lot of these packages
like tensorflow you can set up an
interface into java and other places but
it was designed and has a very high
functionality in both python and r and
it uses data flow graphs to process data
this is nice because as you build these
neural networks you can actually look at
how the data flows through the neural
network they're easy to build machine
learning models robust machine learning
production powerful experimentation for
research i can't even emphasize that
enough it's very easy to go in there and
switch a couple lines in your tensorflow
setup to try out a new setup a new
neural network to see how it works with
your data going through and if it gives
you better results tensorboard for data
visualization and this is another huge
package that people kind of forget as
part of tensorflow put out by google
brain team and tensorflow is now open
source the tensorflow data visualization
is makes it so quick and easy to put out
your data for visual effects uh when
you're working with your ceo or with
your shareholders and of course you can
use both the r and python visualization
packages too since you're usually
running it in python or r let's go ahead
and talk about cross we mentioned
overlapping earlier cross is probably
the most overlapping package out there
and i'll show you why in just a minute
let's start with the creator of cross or
the founder now cross was originally
developed by francois chole he's the
author of cross and it has over 350 000
users and 700 plus open source
contributors that's big cross is
tensorflow might be the biggest or well
most well-known package out there cross
because it overlaps so many other areas
and such a high-end development is
probably the fastest growing package out
there right now and it's got a high
level neural network api written in
python uh so for all us python lovers
and data science a great package to go
from there what makes it interesting is
that it runs on top of tensorflow theano
cntk so it uses their neural networks
underneath and then you use your
definition in cross to define all these
packages so now if you're running
tensorflow and you put cross on top of
it you have both the benefits of cross
and all the tools in tensorflow this is
why cross is the fastest growing neural
network or deep learning package out
there and it's used in several startup
research labs and companies microsoft
research you'll see microsoft has
invested in all of these now so any
place you have any of these coming out
microsoft is part of it of course
microsoft with the cntk is their package
and they're highly invested in that
netflix nasa cern are all using karas
for using their data processing and
their deep learning it's user friendly
as it offers simple apis and provides
clear and actionable feedback upon user
error provides modularity as a sequence
of a graph of standalone fully
configurable modules that can be plugged
together with as few restrictions as
possible these two things makes it so
easy to write a cross code a lot of
times you might be messing with
tensorflow and you turn around you can
do the same cross code in a few lines or
let you know significantly less than
you'd write the same code in tensorflow
so you could use cross on top of
tensorflow and cross it's easily
extensible as a new modules are simple
to add this feature makes cross suitable
for advanced research so from
cross we're going to go into pi torch
and it's authored by adam pasquay sam
gross sumit cantala and gregory shannon
lua based scientific computing framework
for machine learning and deep learning
algorithms so this is coming from the
scientific teams they took and there can
guess it's pi so it's in python but it's
based on the scientific computing and so
they're looking at answers for science
uh and it employed cuda along with c c
plus plus libraries for processing was
designed to scale the product of
building models and overall flexibility
if you're a c c plus plus
programmer and that's your programmer
programming of choice you can see why pi
torch might be really
big jump for you because you know the
back end and you can get in there and
see what's going on with that particular
framework and it's widely used in
companies like facebook twitter google
and you find this interesting because
google like i said you'll see microsoft
and google has their hands in all of
these and i'm guessing that facebook and
twitter have probably investigated the
best use
and use these different frameworks
depending on what they're working on so
it provides a flexibility and speed due
to its hybrid front end enable scalable
distributed training and performance
optimization in research and production
using torch.distributed backend deep
integration into python allows popular
libraries and packages to be used for
clear writing neural network layers in
python so remember it's got that dual
layer uh so if you're running in c plus
or c great language and you can skip
over to python then there's theano and i
had to look this up how to pronounce it
even though i played with it i've only
read the word i've never heard someone
say it and i finally went in there and
looked it up it is theano there's a lot
of pronunciations theno and different
things uh so theano uh it's developed by
the university de montreal and it's
written in python and it really centers
on nvidia and so you have your
integration there to your gps's which is
huge you'll see the gps uh modules like
in tensorflow there's a gps module in
there and in cross obviously since it
sits on tensorflow most of these that's
where they're going is the gps can
process so much faster than a cpu uh so
the python library that allows to define
optimize and evaluate mathematical
expressions involving multi-dimensional
arrays efficiently so when we look at
this we have numpy theano has a tight
integration with numpy for data
computations so if you're a major python
lover and you love the numpy which is
you know the number python such a
central aspect of python and data
science numpy's the way to go and then
he uses the gpus to perform data
intensive computations which are much
faster than on a cpu and it has
extensive unit testing and
self-verification that can detect and
diagnose many types of errors so sienna
is a pretty solid package
and the fact is written in python and is
designed pretty solid on the gpu makes
it a very big contender in our deep
learning array of
platforms out there and then we have
deep learning for java or the dl for
they usually call it dl4j deep learning
for java was developed by a machine
learning group led by adam gibson a
wonderful group i got to meet them
they're a lot of fun it's written in
java and scala and that is big if you
are working in big data and the hadoop
and the spark framework those who jump
out at you right off the bat so we have
our dl4j supports different neural
networks like cnn rnn and lstm cnn is
your convolutional neural network arid
in is your recurrent neural network and
lstm is your long short term memory for
the neural networks you'll see cnn lstm
a convolutional neural network with a
long short term memory it's connected to
the eclipse foundation so the dl4j was
contributed to eclipse foundation
integrated with hadoop and apache spark
i talked about that earlier since scala
spark is written in scala so we're
talking about big data and big data
processing that's a big name to have on
there and the fact that a lot of uh
hadoop your mapreduce is based in java
you can see the connection for the
dl4j in big data and so dl4j brings ai
to business environments for use to
distributed cpus and gpus and right
there distributed cpus and gpus so this
can be run across a huge cluster of
computers quite easily it's designed for
that so if you're working in spark and
you have a hundred computers set up on
different racks this would be a really
solid roll it out the
doorway setup for you so he provides a
distributed computing framework as
training with dl4j occurs in a cluster
as we're talking about cluster
computations includes an n-dimensional
array class using nd4j that allows
scientific computing in java and scala
offers a vector space modeling and topic
modeling toolkit that is designed to
handle large text sets and perform in lp
natural language processing so we looked
at dl4j let's take a look at the cafe
developed at bear that's berkeley
artificial intelligence research so
berkeley's at it again cafe stands for
convolutional architecture for fast
feature embedding it's written in c plus
plus within python interface so again we
have another contender for people who
work in the c plus realm and want to be
able to go back and forth between that
and python generally used for image
detection and classification used in
academic research projects which makes
sense this is coming out of berkeley
startup prototypes and large-scale
industrial applications in vision speech
and multimedia and really when you see
vision speech and multimedia all of
these deep learning are addressing these
particular aspects and more
so it's not a big jump when you talk
about vision there is a little bit there
as far as which ones handle the vision
better because then you're doing
different matrixes you know you have a
xy plot coming in and that's a big deal
that's you'll see that in tensorflow
especially caffe supports gpu and
cpu-based acceleration computational
kernel libraries such as nvidia cudn and
intel mlk so it's integrated a little
bit more on the multiprocessor and the
gpu setups in there we're seeing that
all come together most of the packages
now well nvidia is almost in all of
these as far as the gpu acceleration but
we're starting to see the other ones
migrate in there it offers a high speed
can process over 60 million images per
day with a single nvidia k40 gpu that's
huge 60 million images per day
so when you're training this thing and
you spend a lot of time training and i
mean that's just huge that's amazing so
let's take a look at chainer chainer is
one of those that kind of
i don't hear a lot about but it's still
a contender in our setup in here it is
developed by preferred networks in
collaboration with ibm intel microsoft
and nvidia and there we see nvidia again
they've got their hands and everything
and so does intel microsoft and ibm
that's what puts this at one of the top
contenders it has such a huge backing in
the industrial world it's written purely
in python it runs on top of numpy and cu
pi python libraries so that's
straightforward if you're uh like i said
most of stuff in our machine learning is
heading towards the python environment
because it's so flexible it's currently
one of the top used setups in there and
the chain is written right on top of it
in python and it provides a number of
extended libraries we have the chainer
mn and the chainer rl and the chainer cv
and you'll find in deep learning these
little abbreviations are so many unless
you're working with a specific setup and
you're running it i wouldn't worry too
much about memorizing all of them maybe
get your flash cards out uh but we have
chain or mn which is multiple
nodes rl which is your reinforced
learning and cv
which is your computer vision library
so your images and so when you're
working with with chainer you definitely
want to know what those mean and as you
dig in deeper into it but these are they
have tons of extended libraries these
are a few of the libraries they have
these are the top ones that are used so
it supports cuda computation it only
requires a few lines of code to leverage
a gpu there's our gpu which we're seeing
across the board on all of our different
neural networks and how the how they
apply that is important because some of
them do a better job than others it also
runs on multiple gpus with little effort
so just by its name chainer is designed
to send it out there to the different
aspects and bring them back together
that's what makes this one of the
reasons chainer is being developed so it
provides various network architectures
including feed forward nets conv-nets
recurrent nets and recursive nets and
again now we're starting to dig in deep
into
the neural networks and deep learning as
opposed to the different main players
and most of these cover different
aspects of these you have to really dig
deep to see where these go but chainer
is coming up and it's got some heavy
hitters backing it um it has you know
like i said ibm intel microsoft and
nvidia are part of the development team
there and we're getting down to the end
here we have our microsoft cntk
developed by microsoft research and the
cntk is a deep learning framework that
builds a neural network as a series of
computational steps via directed graph
it supports interfaces such as python
and c plus plus so again now we have one
of the nice things about this is you'll
see it's it's the interfaces are really
spread out so those are the two main
players with python being the more
commonly used one but we're starting to
see c plus coming in there's a lot of
programmers out there who use c plus and
it's used mainly for our handwritten and
you can see some examples here for what
it's used mainly for so it's designed
for speed and efficiency and that's
always that's a big thing because neural
networks just eat up so much processing
power for all the calculations it takes
to program them so it's designed for
speed and efficiency cntk scales well in
production using gpus but has limited
support from the community so again we
have the big hitters behind it microsoft
research but does not have a huge
community support yet it supposed both
rnn and cnn type of neural models
capable of handling image a nice picture
of the guy writing there handwriting and
speech recognition problems so that's a
wrap we covered a number of different
models here we've dived a little bit
into tensorflow probably the biggest
hitter out there right now or the
biggest name out on the market we have
cross probably the biggest growing name
out there since it's able to leverage
both tensorflow and theano and cntk so
it leverages other different products
underneath of it we have the pytorch the
theano the dl4j the cafe the chainer and
the cntk
so this is exciting because all of these
packages people are jumping back and
forth between them because one has the
new tools out that works on something
and then somebody else upgrades there so
it works better you know so
up comes dl4j which processes across
huge pools of data across huge hadoop
networks and has that java interface and
it's like oh okay wow that you can
leverage 100 computers to train your
neural network across all this data
because the training is what takes up
all the resources and tensorflow comes
well how do we set that up the community
under tensorflow then builds their
packages to run their gpus across
multiple data and you can see that these
are just growing with each other and
kind of in their own direction all at
the same time so very exciting very
exciting cutting edge in our artificial
intelligence design and machine learning
hello and welcome to the session on
installing tensorflow my name is mohan
and i'm going to take you through the
process of setting up this tensorflow
development environment as some of you
may be aware it's not that easy to set
up the tensorflow environment there are
several components there are several
possibilities for example you can set up
on windows you can set up on ubuntu now
ubuntu has multiple versions which
version to use and then you have python
which release of python to use whether
to do a pip install whether to do
install using anaconda and how do you
then link it up with jupiter notebook
these are multiple possibilities and it
takes up a lot of time to try all of
these so today what i'm going to do is
show you a tried and tested method of
setting up the tensorflow environment
and this will help primarily those who
are starting with tensorflow so that
they don't have to waste so much time on
setting up the environment in
experimenting with the insulation and
setting up of the environment now what
we are going to do is i will show you a
method by which you you know it is a
tried and tested method and of course
tensorflow homepage has a install page
and it shows you some ways to install
but again the challenge is the same
there are multiple versions multiple
methods shown there so it's highly
confusing for somebody who is new as to
decide which one which path to take so
in today's session what we are going to
do is we will set up tensorflow on
ubuntu and i am going to show you in a
virtual box but then if you are using a
laptop with ubuntu installed you can
straight away use the same method
however we need to keep one thing in
mind that the various releases and
versions of ubuntu and
python and tensorflow not all of them
are compatible with each other so these
versions and releases need to be very
specific so i will tell you which is the
version and releases what combination is
best suited for you to get started and
later on of course you can then
experiment with other possibilities and
other releases and so on once you get
familiar with tensorflow to start with i
would also like to mention that it is a
good idea to install or start with
ubuntu environment or linux any other
linux also but here we will focus on
ubuntu rather than windows so for those
who are already let's say using a
windows system the question may arise
what do we do but there is a easy option
as you can see i am actually using a
virtual box so you need to install
virtualbox let me just show you so this
is the virtual box oracle vm virtual box
and there are tons of videos on youtube
how to install
a virtual box and how to create ubuntu
image i think we will not spend time on
that but if you are using windows
and my preference would be to set up a
virtual box and set up your environment
in ubuntu image so we will start by
assuming that you have an ubuntu
environment especially release 14.04 lts
there are multiple ubuntu versions and
again we will not try to get the latest
and the greatest versions or latest and
greatest releases but the focus here is
to take the releases and versions which
are working and where you will not waste
time so the setup process will be smooth
if you stick to these releases you can
of course experiment later on with other
versions and try out but here we will be
working with ubuntu 1404 lts and we will
use python 3.4 and we will use
tensorflow 1.5 this is a tried and
tested combination and i would also
recommend that you use the same if you
want a smooth start and so let's get
started with that
let me login to my ubuntu system
okay so we have the ubuntu system
running here now if you go to
tensorflow.org
there is a page which
mentions how to install tensorflow and
as you can see there are multiple
possibilities you have ubuntu you have
windows and
mac os and so on and so forth and if you
go to ubuntu for example further you
will get
multiple options whether you want cpu or
gpu and whether you want to do a pip
install or using a virtual native pip
virtual env anaconda and so on and so
forth so all these options are
very complicated or rather very
confusing i would say not complicated
depending on whether you're expert or of
course i am talking about beginners here
but if you click on some of these
options they may look very easy so for
example if you go back and
if you select for example native pip it
may appear like oh this is just you know
one
single or two steps and that's about it
everything gets installed you see here
it should be just one step install it
you say three install tensorflow and
everything gets installed unfortunately
it doesn't work that way so it's not as
easy as so don't get kind of fooled by
the simplicity of the of the
documentation here again it's not their
fault because of the multiple
combinations of releases and so on and
so forth it is not that easy so what we
will do is we will take a slightly
roundabout method which is using
anaconda which has a few more steps but
you're sure that this is going to work
so that is what we are going to do and
that's what i am going to show you so
what are the steps involved of course i
will not go exactly by what they have
mentioned here as i said i will show you
the steps which are again sure shot to
work whereas
here again if you follow just this
document there will be some variations
which they have kind of not documented
so that's the reason i will show you the
steps separately all right so these are
the main four steps you need to download
and install anaconda and then create a
virtual environment with python and the
release as i mentioned is python 3.4 and
we will install tensorflow version 1.5
and then we will install and configure
jupiter which will be our development
environment all right so let's get
started this is our ubuntu and let's get
a terminal started here and
okay yes so
all right so we started the terminal and
then what we'll also do is we'll go to
the anaconda website because we need to
install anaconda we need to download and
install anaconda so for that you need to
go to the anaconda website so you can
just open a browser and
google and you will find anaconda
website
so this is the site anaconda.org
click on this link and it will take you
to the anaconda website
you don't have to sign up or anything
like that just look for the download
anaconda
so just click on that it will take you
to the download pages and it
automatically recognizes that you are on
ubuntu so it will show you the links to
download all right so as you can see it
does
recognize that you are on a linux
operating system so
you can just click on this download and
it will start the download there are two
versions of course python with python
3.6 and 2.7 i
recommend you start with python 3.6 now
just want to clarify that we will be
actually using python 3.4 this is just
for
the initial installation but
subsequently when we set up the virtual
environment you will see there is one
more step there where we set up the
virtual environment there we will
actually be using python 3.4 so just
that you are not confused all right so
it has started the download we just say
no thanks for this and it is downloading
while it is downloading you can
click on
this
link saying how to install anaconda so
there are a couple of steps mentioned
there that we will be using so let me
just in the meanwhile click on this for
some reason the network is a little slow
so it's taking time all right so
once the download is done we will be
using the options that are mentioned
here now the first step of course is we
we are already doing the first step
which is downloading the installer for
linux the second step is not mandatory
so it's an optional step most often you
can actually skip that and third step is
what we are going to do and
since we are using at this point we are
using python 3.6 we should use this
command so basically
the terminal we have opened here is is
to use or to run this command that's the
reason i open this terminal however make
sure that the download is complete
before you run this command so we'll
just wait for a couple of minutes and
we'll come back once the download is
done all right so as you can see the
download is done this is a fairly large
file so if you are on a slow internet or
low internet bandwidth then it might
take quite a while it's about
578 mb and so this is the file now what
you need to do is
you need to go back to this installation
steps and let me minimize this and
yeah so
this is the command that you need to run
so you can just directly copy and paste
this command from here
okay so i do copy right mouse click
now it will ask you a bunch of questions
as documented here so most of them you
need to just say enter or yes and that's
about it except for the last step i will
just show you what i mean and here you
need to do press enter multiple times
just to make sure you agree to all these
agreement
the license agreement and so on and so
forth so once you do multiple
enters it will
bring you to the next step
all right so now here again they say do
you accept the terms you just say yes
and then press enter and here it will
ask you a couple of questions and pretty
much you need to just go for the default
version press enter to confirm you just
say press enter and
this is primarily when it will
pretty much start the installation
process of anaconda this might take a
little while depending again on your
internet speed so you need to have some
patience we will also probably come back
once this installation is done or if it
asks for any further questions
all right so here you'll get again one
more question do you used to
wish the installer to prepend
so you just say yes for this question
and
keep going now the last question
i think we are pretty much at the end
and that is about
microsoft
vss i guess yeah vs code so for this you
can just say no because we will not be
using this
and
that's it you're done so this is a
completion of installation of anaconda
so it's always a good idea to exit and
start a fresh terminal okay so
let's start again terminal
so we are done with the
installation of anaconda the next step
is to create a virtual environment with
python 3.4 so for that this is the
command conda create dash n
and this is the name of your virtual
environment you can give any name but
for easy reference i have given us
tensorflow and we have to specify the
python version as i mentioned earlier we
will be using the combination of python
3.4 and
tensorflow 1.5 now this is not the
latest version python has probably 3.6
at this point at the time of creation of
this video and even tensorflow probably
has the latest version as 1.7 but then
these combinations sometimes may not
work and i found that after several
trials and errors 3.4 with 1.5 seems to
be most reliable and that's the reason i
have chosen this i would recommend you
to try with this first if you're a
beginner and later on maybe you can try
out the other
permutations and combinations all right
one step i just wanted to show you is
before we do the installation or
creation of the virtual environment if
you want to just clarify or confirm
whether anaconda has been installed or
not you can run what is known as
anaconda navigator so you just say
anaconda
navigator
okay we need to edit this part hold on
one second i guess it is
all right so you see here when you start
anaconda navigator
this
anaconda navigator will open up that is
the indication that anaconda has been
installed
properly so that's just a quick check
and you don't have to do anything just
you can go back and close it
once this comes up and
then in the meanwhile let me just open
one more terminal
for the creation of the
virtual environment and
um
yeah so this is your anaconda navigator
and you can just say okay don't show me
just say okay
and
then you can close this
you can say file you can do a file exit
or you can click on close button
whichever
all right so we will exit from here
we have a
terminal open here we will use this for
our next steps all right so what we have
to do now is
type in this
piece of
code
or this command
for some reason copy paste is not
working so
it's a small command so it shouldn't be
that big of an issue so we say conda
and we say
create
so this is the command for creating a
new environment slash
dash n
and then we give the name of the
environment so we will we can give any
name for uh
convenience and just calling it
tensorflow
but you can actually name it anything
and then we need to specify with the
which version of python so we say
pip python
and then that is equal
3.4 okay so it will create an
environment this will take a little
while it will ask you a question just
say yes and then it will be done
so this is just a warning you can simply
ignore that
and
for the question that it asks you just
say yes and i think you should be good
all right so it says do you want to
proceed you say yes then enter
this will again take a little bit little
time so we will probably move forward
and then come back once this is done
all right so
the environment has been created now
it's always a good idea to whenever some
of these steps get over or each step
gets over you just exit the terminal and
start afresh with the new terminal for
some reason sometimes it causes problem
if you continue so i found that it is
a safe practice to each time exit the
terminal and start afresh now that we
have an environment created
we can by the name tensorflow
you can
enter that environment by calling the
command source
activate tensorflow to name whatever
name you have given so you'll see here
once you do that you will get this the
name of the environment will be shown
here so it is like your own again a
special environment within within the
system and uh from here onwards you can
do other stuff like actually installing
tensorflow and so on and you will see
that it has installed python 3 here so
3.4 right so it is installed that's what
we during creation of this uh
environment we wanted python 3.4 so that
is what it is showing but we are not yet
done so we need to still install
tensorflow so in this environment you
need to
run a command which will actually
install the correct combination of
tensorflow now this is as you can see
it's a slightly complicated command pip
install
dash dash ignore install so
what we can do is from within here we
can go and
go to tensorflow
install page and there is a sample code
there you can pick up from there so that
you don't have to type in
so much
so we say tensorflow tensor
flow
dark and i'll also open up probably a
notepad here so that we can construct
that command and go here
you say
ubuntu
if you come further down there will be
by the way we are doing cpu installation
i think uh that is clear we are not
there is a possibility to do gpu as well
we will probably create a separate video
for that
and
if we go here
yeah so
again you probably if you follow the
entire document out here it may still
not work so i do not recommend that for
now at least for beginners but just to
copy this command because this is a
fairly complicated command so this is
much easier to copy from here that's the
reason i'm
on this page
and we will
then modify it according to
yes okay let's say
copy
and don't do it directly here because
that is probably not yet the right
command
let us go and create a notepad
page
empty document
i'll just say
tf.txt
okay this is just a temporary file what
we need to do here is we need to adjust
this command to suit the versions that
we are installing here so let me just
explain what it is what you need to do
so first thing you can get rid of this
one
yes okay now here these parts you can
simply ignore here you need to go and
change it to version
1.5
and i think we are good with that okay
so
the cp34 indicates your python 3.4
so later on when you're trying to
experiment and if you want to
do other combinations of tensorflow and
python version then you can change this
for example you can change this to 3 6
both these places you need to change
this to 3 6 if you're using with python
3.6 and similarly if you want the latest
version which is of tensorflow which is
1.7 you need to change this to 1.7 and
so on but at this point to start with if
you're a beginner i would recommend that
you stick to this tensorflow 1.5 with
python 3.4 this is tried and tested and
it works okay just a word of caution
that just by changing these versions
the whole thing
will not work there may be other places
where you may have to some of the steps
may change so just a word of caution
that just by changing this if you want
to try out with a different version some
of the steps may also change so don't
think that just by changing this just
one particular command you will be uh
fine okay so
that's been my experience so to start
with i would recommend use this
particular combination all right so
it looks good
uh tensorflow 1.5 and
let me
just reconfirm with my notes and i think
it looks good so this is install ignore
1.5 cp34 cp34
and so on okay
okay so let's hit enter
so it started the process again this
might take a little while so we will
pause the recalling and then get back
when the
installation is done okay so
looks like this installation is done
and as always let us
exit and then come back now
you are currently in the environment
virtual environment um and it's a good
practice before you exit out of the
terminal to come out doctor out of the
virtual environment so just like you did
source activate you need to do source
deactivate
and the name tensor
flow okay you will come back to the
original command prompt and then from
here you can
do an exit now we need to validate
whether the tensorflow installation has
gone through properly or not so
the way to validate is to
first start python and then import
tensorflow library see if it imports
without error so that's the best way to
validate so we'll open a terminal
and whenever you want to get into
the environment this is how you have to
do come to environment and then say
source and obviously you can also use
existing
so source activate
tensorflow okay
so we do this and you need to run python
from here remember you should say python
3 because you have installed python 3.4
now here when you say import
tensorflow
as df
when you get back a prompt like this
without any errors that means tensorflow
installation has been successful if
tensorflow was not installed properly
you will get an error saying tensorflow
is not available or module doesn't exist
or something like that so tensorflow
installation is done but now we will
go through the process of installing
jupyter notebook so that you can do your
development so let me just exit
and in order to install your jupyter
notebook which is your which is going to
be your development environment we will
first
install ipython using conda so conda
install ipython and then pip install
jupiter so let's first do the
ipython conda
install
python
again it will ask you a question saying
these are the components do you want to
install you just say yes
all right you say yes
once again it will take a little while
so we might pause the recording and come
back once it is done
great so that did not take much
time anyways so we will
as usual we will exit which is
source deactivate
tensorflow
exit and then we will start a fresh
terminal
in order to install
jupiter
now in some places uh they may say um
install jupiter using pip3
but in my experience it did not work
with pic3 and that's the reason we will
use pip
however just keep in mind you need to
first go to the environment so source
activate
tensorflow
and you need to use this command which
is pip install jupyter usually when
you're on python 3 you use pip3 but as i
said it did not work so
in my experience it works with
install and not p3 so pip install
jupiter
i hope you already noticed that it is
jupy
r
and not j p i
so again it's probably taking a little
while we will pause the recording and
come back once it is done
okay so jupiter installation is also
done
once again
you need to it's a good idea not you
need to but it's a good idea to
come out of this terminal session and
then start afresh
so we exit and we have a fresh terminal
already available here
and we will once again
go to tensorflow
and we say
jupiter
notebook that's how you start your
jupyter notebook
so this looks good now only thing is
since we are running
for the first time what you need to do
is if you come back to your command
prompt it will show you that if you are
running it for the first time it will
say that you need to copy paste this
link so you you can just for the first
time only once you need to do this
copy this
and
paste it in your
browser
and remember this is only the first time
when you're running jupyter you need to
do this
subsequently you don't have to it will
automatically
open up all right so now that we have
jupyter installed and
it starts up we need to test whether
tensorflow
is working fine or not and in order to
do that you can create a new
notebook
and you say
import
tensorflow
as tf and shift enter if everything is
fine tensorflow is installed properly
you don't get any errors and then it
works fine this is
an indication that tensorflow got
installed successfully
and that's about it so that's all about
installing tensorflow with python 3.4 so
remember this is installation of
tensorflow 1.5 with python 3.4
on ubuntu although deep learning is been
around for a while it is just in its
infant stages of development as far as
exploding on the market i mean it is
right now they're building robots with
it deep learning is used to train robots
to perform human tasks music composition
deep neural nets can be used to produce
music by making computers learn the
patterns involved in composing music
image colorization neural network
recognizes objects and uses information
from the images to color them machine
translation given a word phrase or a
sentence in one language neural networks
automatically translate them into
another language google translate is one
such popular machine translator you may
have come across and you'll notice in
here we didn't show any examples of
straight numbers like
projective cells in a business tracking
your favorite stock you can certainly do
those with machine languages but this is
the next level save that for your
regression models your linear regression
where you're actually processing and
crunching just straight numbers with
machine learning and deep learning we're
going to a whole new level as far as
what we can figure out on the computer
what's in it for you we're going to
cover what is deep learning we're going
to take a look at the biological versus
artificial intelligence what is neural
network activation function in your
neural network and the cost function and
how do neural networks work how do
neural networks learn so there's a
little you'll see a switch right there
we just went from how are they working
in the math in the background to exactly
how are they learning we'll be
implementing the neural network we'll do
a gradient descent deep learning
platforms and we'll give an introduction
to tensorflow and implementation in
tensorflow that's google's platform that
they open sourced recently and it's
probably one of the most cutting edges
in deep learning and even it is still in
the infant stage which is one of the
reasons they released it to open source
what is deep learning deep learning is a
subfield of machine learning that deals
with algorithms inspired by the
structure and function of the brain and
you can see we have a nice picture here
we have artificial intelligence which is
kind of the big bubble that encompasses
all these different things we're talking
about this is ability of machine to
imitate intelligent human behavior and
in there we have machine learning
application of ai that allows a system
to automatically learn and improve from
experience and if you looked at any of
our other videos you'll know that
machine learning covers a lot so deep
learning is a subcategory of that but
don't forget machine learning has all
kinds of other tools that people use to
do very basic uh descriptive and
predictive and postscriptive analytics
and then you have deep learning
application of machine learning that
uses complex algorithms and deep neural
nets to train a model let's take a look
at the biological neuron versus the
artificial neuron now remember in the
human brain and this is true for most
animals there are a lot of different
neurons going on so this is a very basic
one i mean there's hundreds of different
cells involved so when we talk about
neural networks this is why it says in a
very infant stage they're really basing
it on just the most basic thing that
we're able to figure out going on in the
neural networks and you can see right
here we have dendrites fetch information
from an adjacent neurons and pass them
on as inputs so you have your data
coming in and your data going out any
computer model should be looking at that
what's coming in what's going out the
data is fed as an input to the neuron so
we look at the artificial neuron you can
see we have our inputs they come in each
one is specially weighted into the
neuron and then the neuron has an output
the cell nucleus processes the
information received from the dendrites
and the neuron processes the information
provided as inputs axons are the cables
over which the information is
transmitted and the information is
transferred over weighted channels so
you can look at that i mentioned weights
briefly but you alter the data coming in
so those weights are what causes
different information coming in to be
weighted differently and processed
differently and the synapses receive the
information from the axons and transmit
it to the adjacent neurons that's in
your biological model and then we look
at the artificial neuron the output is a
final value predicted by the artificial
neuron so as we dig deeper into looking
at the theory behind the neural network
and we kind of flip back and forth
between these because there's two huge
aspects of it one is from the outside
what are you seeing and what's going on
from the inside so you can find to do
what you need to do and give the best
results you can we start off with what
do we feed we feed an unlabeled image to
a machine which identifies it without
any human intervention and so you can
see here we have a circle that comes in
at 784 pixels and it comes in by 28 by
28 and you can see how it colors in the
the circle on there and we put a
triangle in the triangle in also comes
in as 28 by 28 and it has 784 pixels so
you'll see between these two both of
them are
784 pixels this machine is intelligent
enough to differentiate between the
various shapes so that's what we want to
use our neural network to do is to say
hey this is a circle this is a triangle
that's more of a categorical you can
also do a regression model where you're
actually putting out a float value or a
numerical value we'll be looking at the
true false or the categorical model
mostly because that's where you usually
start at the different there is no real
difference when you as far as the way
the internal functioning goes when you
start flipping between them other than
well we'll talk about that in just a
minute so you can actually go between
the two quite easily and the neural
network provides this capability so
we're going to use this capability to
look between those two one of the things
i want you to note in here is that we're
looking at 784 pixels we're looking at
784 inputs that's very different than
stock with a high low or last year's
cells based on date we're looking at
just a couple of numbers and they're
very clear their numbers they're very
clear what they are which is something
you put into a machine learning linear
regression model this is a step up from
that in that we're looking at complex
patterns and how do you figure those
complex patterns out so a neural network
is a system modeled on the human brain
and we looked at that comparing the two
let's go ahead and look deeper into the
neural network itself we have our inputs
coming in so the inputs are fed to a
neuron that processes the data and gives
us an output input and output this is
the most basic structure of a neural
network known as a perceptron so if you
see the term perceptron that's what
we're talking about we're talking about
this single node that has inputs and an
output however neural networks are
usually much more complex let's start
with visualizing a neural network as a
black box and i always love that symbol
it's a black box it's kind of magical we
have our inputs coming in and we want
certain outputs the box takes inputs
processes them and gives an output let's
have a look at what happens within this
box and you can see me there in my
secret agent get up i got my hidden hood
and everything i guess i'm part of the
black skull or something like that group
so let's take a look at what happens
within this magic box and remember we're
skipping back and forth between the
theory of what's going on in the box
which you have to know how to fine-tune
and how to build versus looking at it
from the outside we're programming this
box and we have an input and an output
to the box as a whole within the box
exists a network that is a core of deep
learning and you can see here we're
showing one layer and we have our grid
coming in the network consists of layers
of neurons each neuron is associated
with a number called the bias and you
can think of the bias if you overly
simplify this and we're doing a linear
regression model this is your
y-intercept in your euclidean geometry
you have to have something that offsets
it and so you always have a bias in
these cells neurons of each layer
transmit information to neurons of the
next layer over channels and so you can
see each of our layers going through
from left to right these channels are
associated with numbers called weights
these weights along with the biases
determine the information that is passed
over from the neuron to neuron so just
like the bias is your y-intercept in
euclidean geometry you could look at the
one weight remember this is very
complicated so we're not looking at just
one way you can look at the weight as
your slope of the line or if you're
doing x equals
m y plus c it would be the m value
neurons of each layer transmit
information to neurons to the next layer
and you can see here as they light up
going across into the final layer and
then to the output and in this case the
output is going to be either a square
and this one or it might light up the
other one which is a circle the output
layer emits a predicted output so in
this case we're looking at a
classification a true false is it a
circle is it a triangle is it a square
let's now go deeper what happens within
the neuron so we're going to dig deeper
and start getting a little bit closer to
some of the math don't worry you don't
have to be a calculus expert to know
your differential equations even though
this is one giant differential equation
you don't need to understand those to
understand what's going on within each
neuron the following operations are
performed the product of each input and
the weight of the channel it's passed
over is found this is simply addition
we're going to sum up the weight times
the output from the previous channel and
plus the bias some of the weighted
products is computed this is called the
weighted sum bias unique to the neuron
is added to the weighted sum the final
sum is then subjected to the particular
function and we'll discuss those that
particular function that part is really
important because those functions have a
huge impact on how well your model
performs under different conditions the
final sum is then subjected to a
particular function this is the
activation function so if you ever hear
the term activation function that's what
we're talking about what activates this
cell and what doesn't as we dig deeper
into activation function an activation
function takes the weighted sum of the
input as its input adds a bias and
provides an output and a lot of times
you'll actually see one formula for the
sum of the weight the weighted sum and
the bias you'll just see that as a
single line of everything added together
and here we've broken it apart because
it makes it clear that this bias is not
computed the same as the weighted sums
here are the most popular types of
activation function and i always find
these interesting because at one point i
was sitting at a table with a gentleman
who was finishing his phd he was in his
last year and he said he went through
all this stuff and he ended up just
trying the four different activation
functions on this particular problem he
was working on so knowing the math
behind it doesn't necessarily mean
you're going to know it right away so
even somebody might have a phd and be
doing the calculations on this comes
back out of it and ends up just trying
the different
activation functions to see what's going
to make a difference and a lot of times
that's a final step that's the kind of
thing where you built your whole model
you've come back and you're like wait a
minute can i do a better deal with the
sigmoid function or the threshold or the
rectifier knowing what they're doing is
important so you can explain it to
somebody else and again you probably do
this on a small set of data if you're
working with big data you don't want to
take down the full server farm just to
test out your three different series you
take a small portion of that data test
it and then you put it through to the
big data so let's take a look at this we
have the sigmoid function and it's used
for models where we have to predict the
probability as an output it exists
between 0 and 1. and you'll see this
true of all of our activation functions
we're working with either the cells on
or off it's true or false and there
might be a little variation in there
which as an output could be used to
compute uncertainty in your solution so
if you're getting a 0.7 with this
activation function it might be well i'm
not sure if that's really a square i'm
not sure it's really a triangle and that
might be a flag for it to be looked at
by a human observer at least in today's
models where we're at right now and you
can see here where we have the formula
simply equals 1 over 1 plus e to the
minus x where x is your value coming in
and it's going to give you a result that
looks very similar to the graph on there
which is somewhere between 0 and 1
and right in the middle you can see that
there's a huge
kind of you can go through all the
different values and uncertainties
involved so the sigmoid function is
probably the default on most of them the
next one is the threshold function it is
a threshold base activation function if
x value is greater than a certain value
the function is activated and fired else
not pretty straightforward yes no true
false i don't want to test for
improbabilities i just want a straight
answer i don't want to know if there's a
partial value on there it either is true
or it's false and the rectifier function
it is the most widely used activation
function i would debate that
rectifier is pretty common one although
i see the sigmoid function is used to be
the basic one but it's up there the
rectifier function is very commonly used
because the output of x if x is positive
and zero otherwise and you can see here
again just like
it's either kind of get a value going up
there so max of x of zero so it's it's
again it's like the threshold function
yes no true false uh it's either zero or
it's uh some kind of progressive value
and then we have the rectifier function
i would argue with this because the
sigmoid function used to be the most
common one but with the rectifier
function it now says it is the most
commonly used or widely used activation
function and gives an output of x if x
is positive and 0 otherwise this is kind
of nice because it now says absolutely
not or it gives you a value of
probability now when i say a value of
probability be very careful there i'm
not saying that it's going to tell you
this is 75 chance of being a circle i'm
going to tell you that it says hey if
this says 0.1 it probably needs to be
looked at or 0.2 or 0.3 it's going to
depend on your data as to what that
value means in general that just means
it's flagging it that if it's not a 1
then chances are it needs to be looked
at by a person and reevaluated and
there's a hyperbolic tangent function
this function is similar to sigmoid
function is bound to a range of minus
one to one so you can see there's our
one minus e to the minus two x and one
plus over one plus e to the minus two x
again it's very similar to the sigmoid
function the bonus of the hyperbolic
function is you have that variable
coming through the middle so again you
can look at it and you have a little bit
more weight as far as you can process
that down the line that's a little bit
more advanced than what we're looking at
right now and a lot of times it's not
even necessary in a lot of our different
uses for these activation functions now
we looked at activation functions and i
kind of said those are a little bit like
a black box because even if you know all
the math a lot of times you end up just
playing with them to find out what works
and it also depends on what model you're
working with whether you need a flat yes
no true false or you need to have
something in the middle that says hey
this isn't quite a one you might need to
process this with the human intervention
and you can look at that one example
would be self-driving cars you don't
want a car to be yes no i'm going to go
through the light you want it to be like
okay if it's uh almost yes maybe we stop
and have human intervention so we don't
get an accident cost function is
something you can really see and measure
and is very important the cost value is
the difference between the neural net's
predicted output and the actual output
from a set of labeled training data so
we have our group of data that's a
square circle and since we're looking at
geometrical shapes we've had somebody
already labeled that data they've
already said this is a triangle this is
a square and so if this is coming up and
it's giving us and saying a square is a
triangle and it's saying a triangle is a
circle the output is wrong and so that
output can then be measured in the
versus the actual output and that's the
cost you might also hear this as error
because that's the error value being
returned how far off is it and what
we're looking for is the least cost or
the least error value and it's obtained
by making adjustments to the weights and
biases iteratively throughout the
training process and this this is called
back propagation and we're going to look
in that a little deeper as we look into
an example it's really hard to see when
you're just looking at arrows without
actual numbers and where the flow is
coming from but you can look at this is
here's our inputs they put out a
prediction the prediction comes out and
says hey we've already labeled this data
because we're in training mode and the
training date is off this is the cost
can we send that error or that cost back
and adjust those weights and we do it in
very small increments across large
amounts of data so that those weights
minimize that cost or that error but
what happens within these neurons so
let's look at a little example of this
kind of helps if you have some kind of
visual let's build a neural network that
predicts bike prices based on a few of
its features and we'll see here we have
our cc our mileage and our abs and these
are our three input layers and then we
have the bike price and the output layer
now it doesn't do us very good to just
pump it in from the beginning and pump
it out and to be honest i would use a
machine learning linear regression model
on this since these are just straight
numbers but because we want a simple
example we're going to put this through
and show you as a neural network what
that looks like and we can put a hidden
layer in there the hidden layer helps in
improving the output accuracy and you
could look at this as a bunch of ores so
it might say hey when we compare these
three values on the first hidden layer
neuron we're looking at one set of
features and then we might weigh them in
the second one so these are a bunch of
different ores kind of how the math
comes out and behind the scenes and then
they go out of course to the bike place
or the output layer and each of the
connections have a weight assigned with
it and you'll see here we have a mileage
cc with the weight 1 and weight 2 going
into our first neuron and you'd also
have your abs going in there and so x1
times weight 1 plus x2 times weight 2
plus the bias of 1. and step 2 is our
activation the activation function
coming in there when does this fire and
the neuron takes a subset of the inputs
and processes it and then we go through
we do that with the second hidden layer
neuron and the third one and so on so
you process each layer in order going
forward now when i told you this is in
its infant stage they now have neurons
that fire into the same layer or back a
layer so that you now have a time series
and there's all kinds of wild things
that they're experimenting with on these
layers this basic setup has been around
since the mid 90s it's only now because
of our technology that it's open to
almost everybody to play with it and
that's why i say this isn't an infant
stage in development is this basic math
is here but what we can do with it is
amazing and what they're actually doing
with all these different things is
amazing and so we're just at the
beginning of how to use all these
different tools in our deep learning in
our neural networks uh and so once we
have our hidden layer computed the
information
reaching the neurons in the hidden layer
is subjected to the respective
activation function and so each one of
these fires an activation output
and then those are each weighted to the
final output layer so the processed
information is now sent to the output
layer once again over weighted channels
and you could look at this as each one
of these is i always look at this as
like a group of people they're all
looking at the bulletin board and the
first person says this is what i project
sells for the company in the second
person and the third and so on and then
their perspectives are weighted based on
their expertise so your accountant might
have a very high weight where the
maybe your janitor has a very low weight
because their expertise is not in
accounting and then that goes into the
output layer and once in the output
layer it goes the output which is the
predicted value is compared against the
original value so now we have our output
layer and since we have like already a
list of bikes with their the different
setups and what their value is we can
now generate an error from this the cost
function determines the error in
prediction and reports it back to the
neural network so this is the cost this
is how far off it is this is your error
coming back and as you can see this is a
back propagation going on so now our
error is going in reverse because we
know we're not completely correct on
this particular channel the weights are
adjusted in order to reduce the error so
each time we go back we are changing
those weights to reduce that error and
we change them in small increments you
don't want to fit one input remember you
might have a data pool with a terabyte
of data you don't want to solve for the
first set of data that comes in and that
be the main solution because everything
else will be off this is going to
confuse you that's also called the bias
so we have the bias in the cell where
we're adding a value the kind of like
the y-intercept and we have a bias of
the whole neural network which means it
is weighted towards one set of answers
so we want to make small changes in
these weights so we don't create a bias
and the weights are just in order to
reduce the error or the cost the network
is now trained using the new weights
once again the cost is determined and
back propagation is continued until the
cost cannot be reduced any further so
let's go ahead and plug in values and
see how our neural network works so here
we come in here and initially our
channels are assigned with random
weights this is important because if you
assign them all with the same weight you
might be able to reproduce it but it
turns out that if i put all my weights
as one or all my weights is zero it
takes longer to train where if you have
random weights they already have like a
little bit of adjustment and or is built
in and that will give us a better answer
and train faster our first neuron takes
a value of mileage and cc as inputs so
here comes our computation whatever
those inputs are and we do that again
with the second neuron with those values
coming in you can see here we have
weight three and so on and then our
third neuron coming down and of course
our fourth neuron so we're adding all
these different values coming in here in
our hidden layer the process value from
each neuron is sent to the output layer
over weighted channels so again here's
our weights coming in and we have n1
into n3 and n4 once again the values are
subjected to the activation function and
a single value is emitted as the output
on comparing the predicted value to the
actual value we clearly see that our
network requires training so here we
have it that our bike price
we put out we thought it was worth 2 000
on our random weights and the bike
actually was 4 000 on there guessing
that's not us dollars because that'd be
a very expensive bike but maybe it is
there's some thousand four thousand
dollar bikes out there the cost function
is calculated and back propagation takes
place this is pretty simple you can look
at that as our we're subtracting one
value from the other we square it and
then we take half of that and that is
propagated back up and each layer
generates its own errors let's go back
one because you have your predicted y
and your actual y that goes back to the
first layer and then based on the value
of the cost function certain weights are
changed so we look at the next layer
that error is not the original uh four
thousand minus two thousand square
divided by two this error is based on
the error of each cell generated how far
off is that cell as far as its weights
we're not going to show you it's
actually a very complicated differential
equation and you can probably write it
out if you wanted to you just write out
each formula that goes into the next
level and you add them all together and
you can write it out all the way through
computers make it so you don't have to
and our neural network is considered
trained when the value for the cost
function is minimum so when we get our
error way down as low as we can that's
when our neural network is trained and
there i mean just recently they've come
up with all kinds of different means for
measuring that particular value a little
bit beyond the scope of today's neural
network but you can actually you can
actually see it you know how far do you
do this until the neural network doesn't
need to be trained anymore and you can
over train a neural network now the
tools that we're looking at
automatically let you know when to stop
which is really nice and that is just
like i said we're at the beginning
stages in neural networks it's just
really cool what they can do now and how
much of it's automated and how much of
it is experimental right now let's take
a look at gradient descent but what
approach do we take to minimize the cost
function so here we have a nice error
thing coming in this is our cost or our
error let's start with plotting the cost
function against the predicted value and
so you can see they fit in multiple y's
and these are the errors coming in and
the cost of each of these inputs and
changes going on note we start at a
random point on the curve so usually you
put in you know you pick up your data
and you randomly pick where to start in
your data a lot of times you just run it
from the beginning because you're going
through so much data it's not that big
of a deal but you start with one point
going in so your forward propagation
goes through you're going to go ahead
and find your cost or your error it
points out on the curve and you can see
how we're plotting it right here since
the gradient at this point is positive
we may move right so we're going to move
a little bit to the right on here and
this time the gradient is negative we
move a little bit to the left eventually
we try out the point where the gradient
is zero this is the least value of cost
function you have to be a little careful
with this because this particular i mean
they make it look nice and simple in
this graph sometimes these curves look
like stair steps and so there is global
minimums and then there is local there
might be a local point where the
gradient is zero but it's not the global
one so it might be way off to the left
where it just happens to step down a
little bit and you think you're in the
right gradient and with that we have all
the right weights and we can say our
network is trained so here we have um
just some major these are some of the
big names out there right now in
development for deep learning platforms
tensorflow which we'll actually do an
example in a minute deep learning for j
which is in the java platform so if
you're a java programmer by the way
tensorflow is accessed most people are
using python to access it but it is a
system that's kind of separate from a
lot of the programming languages which
makes it a lot more
flexible as far as used deep learning 4j
is java based and then cross is just
exploding right now and this is
interesting cross is uh working with
tensorflow it actually can sit on top of
tensorflow and it can also do its own
thing so if you're studying deep
learning you're getting into it you'll
want to know the basics of tensorflow
but you also are going to want to know
the upper level of cross sitting on top
of tensorflow we're just looking at
tensorflow today though in our example
and there's also torch on there there's
a bunch more that we didn't list on here
even sk learn or the side package in
python has a neural network you can
program a very basic one and it is the
same basic one that you could do in
tensorflow if you stripped everything
out of it and then tensorflow has a lot
of tools they've added in and so has
cross but we're gonna be looking
specifically at tensorflow in our
example and tensorflow is an open source
tool used to define and run computations
on what they call tensors very common
language now so more and more we see the
term tensor as being a standard in the
deep learning language and this was
originally developed by google so let's
take a little bit big in there what are
tensors tensors are just another name
for arrays so a tensor of dimension five
you can see here we have a b k m q
whatever so it's an array coming in and
the tensor of dimension five four more
like a picture very common to see that
in the picture you can also see a tints
are even more detailed in the picture as
we go to the next one tensor dimension
three three three this is 3d space you
might have a picture that also has
colors that might be the third dimension
you might have four dimensions because
you have both your grid and your
different color channels and your z plot
you can see where you can now process a
very high level set of data coming in
whether as an image or features they
could be features that have nothing to
do with images so there's a lot of stuff
you can do now with the tensors coming
in this is where the term tensorflow
comes from so we have right now that
tensorflow is the most popular library
in deep learning and i did mention cross
now works with tensorflow so there's a
lot of stuff you can do between the two
uh it's an open source software library
developed by google so they hit a
roadblock and they realized hey this is
an infant stage technology you know we
thought it was going to be the next
greatest thing and we were going to have
a hold on it but it's really infant as
far as how it's applied and what we can
do with it let's open source it so
everybody can work on it let's take it
to the next level and that's really what
open source does to a lot of these
packages when they release them and you
can run on either a cpu or a gpu so when
we look at the details if you have your
graphic processing units what's nice
about those is they run a lot faster the
downside is you have to play with them a
little bit to get them up and running
and it's a hardware upgrade when we run
it i'll be running it in the cpu mode i
have played with it in my gpu on my
personal computer you know it does
increase the processing but i did run
into some version problems with my
python and stuff like that and when i
did finally work it out i went back to
the cpu because it didn't increase my
speed enough for what i was working on
but in a larger group you might be able
to put that on if you're working with a
larger stack of computers you might want
to run it in the gpu you can create a
data flow graphs that have nodes and
edges so there's our edges coming in we
didn't talk about edges but this very
up-and-coming way of looking at your
analytical data is how do different
nodes connect what do those edges look
like in between them and it's used for
machine learning applications such as
neural networks it is mostly a neural
network but they have all kinds of tools
which sit on top of our basic neural
network they have new stuff evolving
into the tensorflow library so it's very
much just exploding great time to jump
into tensorflow there's all kinds of
cool things you're doing with it and all
kinds of cool applications you can now
use tensorflow for so let's take a look
at implementation in tensorflow and
we're going to build a neural network to
identify handwritten digits using the
mnist database or the mnist database and
that stands for modified national
institute of standards and technology
database it is a collection of 70 000
handwritten digits and the digit labels
identify each of the digits from 0 to 9.
this is a cool example because it's
simple enough that you could actually
run this through some basic machine
learning categorizing algorithms and
train them and you'll get about the same
answer because again it's it's simple
grid the digits on the grid don't have a
huge amount of variation like you would
say an automated driving car looking at
the environment so you can still do this
with a lot of your
different linear models and stuff like
that you can solve this and you'll get
about the same answer when i ran a
comparison between tensorflow and
between some basic uh regression models
or category models in machine learning
they came up pretty even as far as their
output so this is kind of where we start
to see the complexity of something
coming in in this case a tensor you know
or a grid of information where the deep
learning model does as good as the
regular models and when you get past
this kind of complexity and features
suddenly the neural networks come up
with better answers better solutions and
a better build and that's why there's
such a move into neural networks is we
live in a complicated world it's just
really cool we can do with this so the
handwritten digits from the nist
database they come in the data set is
used to train the machine a new image of
a digit is fed and the digit is
identified and if you've looked at any
of our other machine learning tools
where we're doing training where we
train our model to fit and then you test
it out this will look pretty familiar
and there is some tools out there for
say untrained categorizing where it's
just looking for features that fit
together so there are tools that don't
need that training but this is where we
talk about neural networks we do need to
train them and this is what we're
looking at
so for this i'm going to use the
anaconda navigator just because it's a
very nice visual tool you might be in
pycharm or one of your other ides for
editing python because we are looking at
python tensorflow and under anaconda we
have the notebook which is something we
use pretty regularly and they have the
jupiter lab the jupiter lab is the
jupiter notebook but with tabs and a few
new features so we'll be using the
jupiter lab today and under the
environment you'll want to go ahead and
if you haven't yet you'll see that i
have a number of different setups in
here right now i have the python version
3 6 and the tensorflow in this case i
have tensorflow 1.12 if we scroll down
you can see that here we go tensorflow
and it's version 1.12 and in here if you
haven't yet you'll need to install those
and go in and just open our terminal and
if you've never used the anaconda or if
you're in your other thing you might
have something simple like pip conda is
what i use for my install and you can
simply do conda install tensorflow that
should bring in the most current version
now when i installed this a few months
ago python version i'm not going to run
this because i already have installed on
here python version 3.7 the newest one
out still had a couple glitches with the
tensorflow i believe they fixed it as of
writing of this but um i'm going to
stick with three sixths just so i don't
get any surprises on there so this is
python version 36 with tensorflow 1.12
on here and if you haven't installed it
yet you also want to install numpy for
this example that's numbers python or
numpy
you just simply run install on there
keep in mind if you're in anaconda
and you've created one of these
environments specific to this keep with
conda if you're going to use conda if
you're going to use pip keep with pip
don't install one package with pip and
one under conda because that's how they
track those version numbers and how they
fit together and you can end up with a
problem they don't pip doesn't see conda
and vice versa so just keep that in mind
when you're running your installs we'll
go ahead and open up jupiter lab and
we're going to launch that so here's my
jupiter lab one of the really cool
features of jupiter lab is you have tabs
now so you can open up multiple
notebooks this is nice because i have my
notes i'm working on and then our actual
window we're looking in and we'll go
ahead and zoom in a little bit here
there we go so you have a nice
hopefully easy to see fonts and then
we'll go ahead and do a simple or get
our imports out of the way and so we're
going to import our tensorflow as tf
that's pretty much a standard for
tensorflow numpy our numbers python as
py and we'll import our matte plot
library as plt again these are very
common so if you see tf or py or plt
this is a standard that most people use
do you have to no you could just do
import numpy instead of doing as py and
then from tensorflow dot examples
this is always nice because they
actually include data set we're going to
play with so we're going to import input
data so there's our data coming in
that's all we're doing is telling it
this is where it's coming from and if we
can tell where it's coming from we need
to go ahead and create a variable with
that information in it and we'll just
call this uh mnist nist or minst you
know i don't really know how they
pronounce that i should probably look
that up it's a very common data set to
use and there's our input data and we're
going to read data sets and this is if
you look at this we imported input data
from our tensorflow and so this is a
tensorflow read statement for their
tutorials so this isn't like some
special python setup this is just their
setup makes it easy to pull it in so
once we get into their data sets we need
to go and tell what kind of data set and
again this is what we brought in but
it's going to be the ninth data and this
part is very important one
hot equals true this means that instead
of importing a value from zero to nine
we evaluate the data set it's going to
bring it in as one hot whenever we see
one hot encoder we're flattening that
out and we have true false for zero true
false for one true false for two so our
output if you remember from our output
uh from the slide we did earlier uh in
this case i grabbed the one for bike
price it doesn't really matter which one
we use this has one output so we have
our bike price on this we're going to
have instead of one output we're going
to have 10 outputs representing each of
the digits in there and this code really
isn't going to show us anything it's
good to see what we're actually looking
at so let's go ahead and do a figure ax
equals go into our plot library subplots
10 comma 10. and that is if you remember
we talked about tensor tensor being data
coming in this is a 10 by 10 grid or 100
pixels on there and if we're going to
display it uh let's go do k
0 for i in range 10 just a simple loop
through on the data let's do what is it
for j in range 10 so i actually
misquoted that 10 uh 10 by 10 is not the
actual size of the pixels uh the actual
pixels are going to be um we look at the
shapes and we'll get to that in just a
second here we'll take a quick look at
the shape on there uh turns out they're
what are they are i believe 28 by 28. uh
so let's take a look at that and we're
just going to plot these what are we
looking at what are we working with as a
data scientist you should always be
looking back at your data and seeing
what it looks like and get that human
perspective because you just never know
you know the the computer may put
something out that looks makes no sense
and at that point you want to go back
and reevaluate what you did uh so we're
going to go ahead and plot we're going
to plot 10 digit you know 10 of the
digits by 10 of the digits and here's
our ax we'll create the ij on our
subplots and we're gonna do an image
show we're gonna look at the training
image for images of k and then we wanna
reshape this we're gonna reshape this
and we're gonna reshape this 28 by 28.
that's how i knew i had it wrong it's
because i looked down my notes it's like
oh no that says 28 it's not 10 by 10.
and i should know that already because
i've done enough messing with this data
set that i should remember but it's 28
by 28 and the aspect we're going to do
is auto and this is all if you look at
this here's our variable nist the nist
is coming from dataset so this is all
part of the tf tensorflow learning or
examples tutorial in there and then
we'll go ahead and do k
plus equals one so we just keep paging
through our different images and let's
see what that looks like let's go ahead
and do a plot
show and we'll go ahead and run this so
we can take a look and see what we have
here and so we have a nice plot here and
you can just see that we have uh some
random numbers showing up and each one
of these little subplots if you're
wanting a copy of this code put a note
down in the youtube video and let us
know or come visit us at
www.simplylearn.com and we'll send you
out a copy of what we're working on and
get a copy of that for your own setup uh
so now we've taken a look we can just
see we have here's our pictures that are
coming on we plotted them so we have an
idea of what we're looking at let's go
ahead and print let's look at the shape
of the features uh so when we have this
we have our nist train images and we'll
do the shape on there let's take a look
and just see what we're looking at
as far as uh our count and everything
and so you can see here we have 55 000
that's basically how many images we have
and this by 784 and in this data set
there's also our labels so let's take a
look at that we have our next train
labels shape let's take a look and see
what that looks like uh and there we
have 10 because there's 10 digits so we
brought in that's our output we're
looking at and so we have there we go 55
000 they match they should match because
you should have equal numbers in both of
those you know here's our data in and
here's our answer if you remember this
is uh a bunch of zeros and with one each
each one will be zero zero zero one
would be what letter four or something
like that so let's take a look at what
our one hot encoding did for the first
observation and this is when we're
exploring data you really want to dig in
there and just see what the heck am i
looking at so we're going to look at the
labels and this would be the first label
that comes up and we'll go ahead and run
this and we look at that you can see
this is what i'm talking about zero zero
our one is zero two is zero three is
zero four zero five is zero six is zero
seven equals one so our very first label
is a seven but a very first label comes
up that it's a seven and so we don't
have like zero through nine we have a
bunch of zeros and just the one to mark
it as a seven on here so now we've kind
of looked a quick look at the data and
in here you might ask some questions
like what is 784 24 times 24. remember
that's the size of our grid on there or
our tents are coming in so 784 is a
setup on there and we've gone through
all this viewing the data we'll go ahead
and start looking at our tensorflow so
let's take our x variable this is going
to be our training set we'll do a
placeholder and then we're going to have
these come in as float now if i remember
correctly they're actually you know 0 or
1 for the values because they're either
but we have them coming in as a float
value and we have a little bit of a
shape coming in here and there's our 784
uh so we let it know that this is what's
what our input is for our tensorflow and
this is our training set so we'll just
put a label on there to help us track
that train set and then w and with w
we'll go ahead and do tf variables and
we'll do this as
zeros variables to have zeros and we'll
set this as
784 by 10 10 being the output 784 being
our number of variables in and this is
our weights remember we have a bias in
there too and i'll go back over this in
just a second as we see how that fits
together in our tensorflow and we'll do
this one with our variables again we
have 10 so we're going to do the bias we
do the same kind of format and set up on
here and so we'll do that as as tf 0s of
10 so we'll just create an array of 10
there and this is our bias so with these
three lines um and there's actually
they're coming out with the eager
execution which would bypass some of
what we're doing but this is important
to understand is the first thing you
have to do with tensorflow is we have to
allocate a space for the variables in
our tf placeholder and our tf variable
with our weights and our biases this
actually hasn't done anything yet so all
it is is placeholders that's why it's
okay to use zeros you could have just as
easily used ones or anything else and it
wouldn't matter the next stage is to go
ahead and set up some of the functions
going on but before we do that just note
that this hasn't done anything even if i
execute it all it's done is created
placeholders until we do the final
initialization and so we need to go
ahead and set up we'll do y equals t f
dot n n dot soft max and the code for
this is tf.mattmole xw plus b and this
is our uh sum let's just put a note here
so we can keep track of what's going on
we're finding weighted sum of inputs
plus the bias uh so there's our plus b
the bias and then we need to go ahead
keep them let's do y underscore and
again another placeholder and this one
will set it's actually we'll put in as
tf placeholder on here tf placeholder
float nun 10 there's our one hot encoder
going on there so our 10 values coming
out and we'll do a cross
entropy on here and this is going to be
minus tf reduce
sum and we'll do y here's our y under
square which is remember we have your y
output and your actual output uh so this
will be our y underscore times the t f
log of y and then finally before we do
the actual initialization of all our
variables we'll set up our train step
this equals our gradient descent
optimizer very important remember we
looked at that chart on our
slides and so we've set up all these
formulas and here's our gradient descent
optimizer and as it keeps looking it
keeps looking for that zero value that's
what we're doing with that particular
formula so let's take a look and see
what we're doing here we just put
together all of our pieces for
tensorflow and you know the devil's in
the
details we have here our training set
coming in we have to put a placeholder
on there we have our
variables with their weights we have our
biases coming out and then we put in our
the weighted sum so here's uh summizing
our summation here then we have our y
variable output so there's our y um how
it works and then of course the actual
output on there and then we have our
cross entropy coming in and that's our
minus tf dot reduce sum the y times the
tf log of y and then the training step
gradient descent optimizer and we're
using a 0.01 in this and we're going to
minimize cross entropy so we're going to
let it do all the work so once we've set
up all of these different layers we've
allocated for them we need to go ahead
and initialize them so we're going to do
an init tf initialize and it's going to
be all variables one of the cool things
is they're in the process of doing away
with this so all these steps would be
bundled into one instead of having to
add placeholders you initialize them in
the same process going on and then
finally everything in tensorflow is
based on your session now this is
changing that there's other options to
be able to run this but we want to go
ahead and do a session there's our tf
which is a tf session and then we want
to go ahead and do session run and what
are we going to run well we did
initialization of all our variables uh
so this is what we're running and this
is where actually once we do this we
actually create our tensorflow object so
this whole piece of code right here is
our tensorflow object we have our input
coming in with our weighted variables
coming in our soft max for our metamode
going out how does it added together for
our y value and then we have the actual
float value coming out checking on our
all the way down so you can see all the
different stages going through that
we're setting up and this is one of the
reasons that a lot of people like
tensorflow is because you can designate
all these different pieces one step at a
time this is also one of the reasons
people don't like tensorflow is because
you have to designate all the different
layers coming down and there's a lot of
steps being made right now to minimize
this to make it either easier to
automate it or to allow you to do more
complicated things and all those steps
are still at play so it's worth looking
into the more advanced version of what's
going on with cross on top of tensorflow
it's also important to understand what's
going on in these individual levels if
you're going to play with them it's
important to understand hey what's going
on with the
finding the weighted sum of the inputs
plus the bias because there's other ways
to do that there's all kinds of other
tools in there now but this is the basic
setup that you want to do on a
tensorflow coming in and we want to go
ahead and just run and init our
tensorflow so let's go ahead and do that
let's run this we do get a warning here
because there's a move to use global
variables this is one of the changes
they're making but as far as this
example is not going to make a
difference because we're doing once we
initialize it this is initializing our
variables and again these are only
placeholders up here until we initialize
them and i would highly suggest put a
note down there or go over to
simplylearn.com and let them know and
have them email you a copy of the code
so you can actually play with this code
right here because this is the body of
what's going on in tensorflow this is
the build in neural networks and then
once we've done that now comes kind of
the fun part is we need to go ahead and
train it so we've created our tensorflow
we've created our network and now we
need to go ahead and train it uh so
let's put together that training code
and let's just do uh for i and range
1000 0 to 1000 so we're just going to
look at uh the first 1000 in our
training and the way we pull that data
from our mints train next batch of 100
uh so you look at this we're going to be
doing groups of 100 and then there's
going to go through a thousand of them
this is very important that tensorflow
builds this in this is one of the
downsides of doing sklearn or one of the
older packages is they don't let you
batch groups in they wanted to have it
all up front and then you have to build
your own batch programs right now this
let's just go ahead and do that and you
can see here we have batch x of s batch
y of s so there's our x and our y you
can look at this as our training of x
and our train of y or the data in and
the answer in uh and then we simply do
our session run uh so here's our session
that we've created we're going to run it
and we want to do the train step where
we initialized our train step up here in
our tf and so there's our train step
feed it's a dictionary dictionary coming
in which we're going to create right
here is x is our batch x of our sample
comma and our y underscore is going to
be our batch of our y sample uh and so
this goes through and we've now hit the
run button and we've trained our session
we've trained this setup on here and
once we've trained it then we need to go
ahead and find out how good our accuracy
was and actually start running some
predictions through there so we'll go
ahead and create a correct prediction
when this is where our tf.equal we'll
use our arg max y of one and tf argmax
of y of underscore of one to help us get
the correct predictions on there and we
wanna use that to feed into an accuracy
and so our accuracy is going to be tf
reduce
mean and we'll take that and we'll do a
cast and this is the correct prediction
that we're sending in there and it is a
float value keep it simple and let's go
ahead and print this out so we can see
what we're looking at so what are we
printing out uh we need to do a session
run this session runs going to be on the
accuracy where did accuracy comes from
this is our we're casting our tf on
there with the correct predictions on
that so here's our accuracy feed in so
it needs a dictionary for the data
coming in we're going to create our
dictionary and x is going to be our nist
test images and y underscore there is
going to be our nist dot test labels let
me just double check and make sure i
have that typed in there correctly there
we go and let's go ahead and run that
and see what comes up and we end up with
a
0.9165 for our accuracy which means our
trained neural network does a pretty
good job letting us know what these
different symbols are i'm guessing that
a seven and a three and a four uh
something that as humans we kind of take
for granted i even have trouble reading
this so i don't know if i would be able
like that first one i would sit there
for a long time figuring out that's a
seven versus a two that could have
easily been a two to me so you can see
we do a pretty good job analyzing this
data and this is used to analyze
something very complicated on these
images very different than just a
straight value of cost of sales and
here's our return and our marketing we
can now create this nice neural network
that does all kinds of cool things hello
and welcome to this session on what is
tensorflow today we're going to see what
is deep learning very briefly and then
we will talk about what are the various
libraries that are available for
developing deep learning applications
and then we will focus on tensorflow and
what are the various advantages why we
should use tensorflow what is tensorflow
and then we will talk about what are
tensors which are as the name suggests
tensorflow consists of tensors and then
they are executed in a certain graphical
format of flow like a graph and that's
why it is named as such tensorflow and
we will see how to write programs in
tensorflow the programming language of
course will be python but there is a
certain way in which you write a deep
learning application or a program in
tensorflow so we will take a look at
that this is a basic introductory
session for beginners and then we will
see one implementation of tensorflow
code one full end to end and that's
pretty much it what you can expect from
this quickly wanted to mention that
there are certain prerequisites before
you actually go through this the
expectation is that you at least have
some idea about some programming
language and preferably python if you
know python absolutely it will be much
easier to understand the code as such
but even if you know any other
programming language i think
it will be okay and you will at least be
able to understand the python code in
addition to that this also involves
especially the case study you will or
the case implementation you will be able
to understand only if you have some idea
about machine learning so in case you
are very new to machine learning and
python everything then it may be a good
idea to check other tutorials that we
have uploaded on let's say about python
and also about machine learning so that
you get a basic understanding and then
come back here otherwise it may be very
difficult to understand this tutorial
all right so having said that let's get
started so what is deep learning again
this video is not about deep learning
but there are other videos we have
created in detail about what is deep
learning in this video we'll just touch
upon the basics so that that's like a
nice segue into tensorflow so deep
learning is
in a way a subset of machine learning
and we use primarily neural networks in
deep learning and the underlying
technology behind artificial
intelligence is deep learning and here
we teach them how to recognize let's say
images or voice and so on and so forth
so it is a learning mechanism but here
unlike traditional machine learning the
data is far more complicated and far
more unstructured like it could be
primarily in the form of images or audio
files or text files and one of the core
components of deep learning is neural
network and a neural network somewhat
looks like this there is something known
as an input layer and then there is an
output layer and in between there are a
bunch of hidden layers so typically
there would be at least one hidden layer
and anything more than one hidden layer
is known as a deep neural network so any
neural network with more than three
layers all together right is known as a
deep neural network all right so what
are the functions of the various layers
let's take a quick look so the input
layer accepts the input so this could be
in the form of let's say if it is an
image it could be the pixel values of
the images so that's what the input
layer does and then it passes on to the
hidden layers and the hidden layers in
turn perform certain computations and
they have what is known as
as a part of the training they have
these weights and biases that they keep
updating till the training process is
complete and each neuron has multiple
weights and there will be one bias and
these are like variables and we will see
when we go into the tensorflow code what
we actually mean by that and so that's
what the hidden layer does it does a
bunch of computation and passes its
values to the output layer and then the
output layer in turn gives the output it
could be in the form of a class so for
example if we are doing classification
it tells us which class a particular
image maybe belongs to for example let's
say if this is a image classification
application then the input could be a
bunch of images of maybe cats and dogs
and the output will be like it will say
okay if this is activated this gives a
zero and this gives a one that means it
is a cat if this gives a one and this
gives a zero that means it is a dot so
that is a kind of a binary
classification and that can be extended
with multiple neurons on the output side
to have many more classes for example or
it can also be used for regression as
well not necessarily only classification
again since this video is not about deep
learning or machine learning or neural
network we will probably not go into a
lot of details but you can check other
videos where we have given a lot more
details about neural networks and deep
learning and so on so in order to
develop a deep learning application how
do you go about primarily there are two
or three components that are required in
order to develop deep learning
application you need obviously a
programming language so typically python
is used and that's what we are going to
use in this particular video but you can
also use other languages like java or c
plus plus and so on and there are some
libraries that are readily available and
for primarily for doing
machine learning and deep learning
programming so these are a list of
libraries these are by no means the
exhaustive list but some of the most
common ones like keras theano tensorflow
and so on and so forth tensorflow has
nowadays become very very popular this
is developed by google and it is an open
source library and keras was there
before now keras has actually now become
a part of tensorflow as well so it is
one player about tensorflow so in that
sense they're well integrated so
combination of keras and tensorflow is
uh pretty good then of course you have a
torch and tl4j and so on and so forth so
there are multiple libraries but this
video is about tensorflow and we will be
focusing on tensorflow what are the
benefits of tensorflow and what are its
components and our towards the end we
will show you a code in python we've
written a code in python by the way
tensorflow can be used with multiple
languages it supports multiple languages
though python is by far the most popular
language so let's take a look at what
exactly is tensorflow and why we are so
excited about tensorflow so tensorflow
offers
apis now we can earlier without when
these libraries none of these libraries
were there even then we were doing
people were doing machine learning and
deep learning and so on but the coding
mechanism was much more complicated what
these libraries like tensorflow offer is
they provide kind of a high level api so
that we don't have to go really deep
into writing all the stuff that is
required let's say to prepare a neural
network and to even configure or even uh
to program a neuron and so on right so
these are done by the library so all you
need to do is they offer a higher level
api you need to use that api and call
that api and maybe pass the data and
that would pretty much it's much easier
rather than actually going down and
writing everything by yourself so
tensorflow that way it offers apis for
to write your code in python or even c
plus plus and so on other languages java
as well it has an integration with r as
well apparently okay and it supports
cpus as well as gpus now deep learning
applications are very compute intensive
especially the training process
needs a lot of computation it takes very
long as you can imagine because the the
data size is large and there are so many
iterative processes there are so much of
mathematical calculations matrix
multiplication and so on and so forth so
for that if you perform these activities
on a normal cpu typically it would take
much longer but gpus are graphical
processing units you must have heard
gpus in the context of games and so on
because where you need the screen needs
to be of high resolution and the images
need to be of high resolution and so on
so gpus as the name suggests graphical
processing unit were originally designed
for that but since they are very good at
handling this kind of iterative
calculations and so on now they are kind
of they're being used or leveraged
rather for doing or developing deep
learning applications and tensorflow
supports gpus as well as cpus so i think
that's one of the major advantages of
tensorflow as well now again what is
exactly tensorflow it's a open source
library developed by google and open
source and primarily for deep learning
development but tensorflow also supports
traditional machine learning by the way
so if you want to do some traditional
machine learning we can do it however it
is probably a bit of an overhead to use
tensorflow for doing traditional machine
learning and this is really good for
performing deep learning activities and
again if you want to get into more
details about what's the difference
between machine learning and deep
learning there is another video about it
you can probably take a look at that
video what else it is developed
originally for large numerical
computation so originally when
tensorflow was developed they never
thought of it as keeping deep learning
in mind but ultimately it so happened
that it's really very good for deep
learning development and therefore
google has open sourced it and
tensorflow as the name suggests the data
is in the form of what is known as
tensors these are like multi-dimensional
arrays and they are very handy in
handling large amounts of data and we
will see that as well as we move forward
and then of course the execution
mechanism is in the form of graphs so
that makes it much easier to execute
this code in a distributed manner across
a cluster of computers and and also
using gpus and so on and so forth right
so that's a quick overview about what is
tensorflow we will see little bit more
detail the two major components that is
basically the tensors and the graphs
let's take a look at what they are so
what are tensors tensor is as i
mentioned earlier it is like a
multi-dimensional
array in which the data is stored now
when we are doing deep learning
especially the training process you will
have large amounts of data and the data
is in typically in a very complicated
format and it really helps when you are
able to put this use this or store it in
a compact way and so tensors actually
offer a very nice and compact way of
storing the data handling the data
during computation this is not really
for storing on your hard disk or things
like that but in memory when you are
doing the computation tenses are really
really very handy in terms of keeping
the data compact because they are like
multi-dimensional arrays so the data is
stored in tensors and then it is fed
into the neural network and then you get
the output all right so there are some
terms associated with tensors let's get
ourselves familiarized one is uh the
dimension and another is the rank so
what is dimension typically dimension is
like the number of elements in a way so
for example this is a five by four
dimension tensor and then you can have
again the multi dimensions right so you
can this can be like three by three by
three so that is uh the dimension and
then you have ranks so what are tensor
ranks ranks are basically traditionally
we would have thought of as dimensions
that is actually in this case it is
called rank so it becomes easier when we
see examples so a tensor's rank is
supposed to be zero when there is only
one element we also call this as scalar
so just one element and it's not really
a vector it's just an element like 200
it's also known as a scalar so such a
tensor is supposed to be having a rank
of zero then you have let's say one
dimensional array this is a vector with
a row of elements this has rank of one
now if you have traditionally what we
called as a two dimensional like a
matrix for example then the rank is two
and in this case the rank is three and
it can have more ranks as well as i
mentioned it is like a multi-dimensional
array so you can have rank five six and
so on okay so those are the
terminologies in tensorflow terms
dimensions and ranks so this is just to
make sure that we are picking the same
language so whenever we talk about the
rank of a tensor you understand what
exactly is meant by that now in addition
to tensors in which the data is actually
stored all right so the data is stored
in the tensors and then once you have
the data there is a computation that
needs to be done now the computation
happens in the form of graphs so what we
typically in a tensorflow program what
we do is it's not like traditional
programming where you just write a bunch
of lines and then everything gets
executed in sequence here we prepare
graphs various nodes and then these are
executed in the form of a session and
they use the data from these tensors now
i know this is a slightly new concept
for a lot of you so it may be a little
difficult to probably understand in the
first
cut but when we look at the code when we
go into the tutorial the code
walkthrough i think that time it will
become much clearer as well but to start
with just uh we need to keep in mind
that we have to first prepare a graph
and when you're preparing the graph no
none of the code is actually getting
executed you write the code to prepare
the graph and then you execute that
graph so that's the way by creating a
session that's the way tensorflow
program works so and each of these
computation is represented as what is
known as a data flow graph and we will
also see that whenever you start
tensorflow when you create an object
tensorflow object there will be what is
known as a default graph and then if
required i know probably in the
beginning it may not be required but in
more advanced programming you can
actually have multiple graphs instead of
the default graph you can create your
own graph and have multiple graphs and
use it as well but there is always
whenever you create a tensorflow object
there will be a default graph and this
will be very nicely illustrated in the
example code that we will take to
explain this so there it becomes much
clearer than in these slides so the
graph gets executed and it processes all
the data that we are feeding all the
external data will be fed in the form of
what is known as placeholders and then
you have variables and constants again
this will also become clear when we take
a look at the code and once you have the
graph then the execution can be enabled
either on regular cpus or on gpus and
also in a distributed mode so that the
processing becomes much faster as i
mentioned the training of the models in
deep learning takes extremely long
because of the large amount of data and
therefore using tensorflow actually
makes it much easier to write the code
for gpus or cpus and then execute it in
a distributed manner so this is how the
tensorflow program looks so there is uh
you need to build a computational graph
that's the first step and then you
execute that graph so the first step is
to write the code for preparing the
graph and then you create what is known
as a session and then in that session
you ask the session to execute this
graph so this will again become much
clearer when we look at the code now
what are the various elements of a
tensorflow program as i mentioned
tensorflow program is slightly different
from regular programming that we do so
even if you're familiar with python this
may still be new for you the way you
write a tensorflow program is different
from the regular python programming that
you would have done or even machine
learning program you would have written
some machine learning program using
scikit-learn or regular python libraries
this is different from even that so let
us see what are the various elements so
first of all the way we handle data
inside of a program itself is a little
different from how we normally do in a
normal programming language a variable
is a variable in your program right so
you have anything that can keep changing
you just create as a variable or even
constants in fact are actually created
as variables but in tensorflow the
storage in the program consists of three
types one is constants another is
variable and the third is a placeholder
so and they are there is a lot of
difference between these types and we
will see how they vary and how they are
used and so on so constants are like
variables which cannot be changed so for
example if you define a constant like
this this is how you define a constant
by the way the simplest format is like
this like for example b is equal to
tf.constant and then you give a value
here a slightly more advanced version is
you also specify the type so you say
tf.constant 2.0 tf load 32. so the type
is of type float now in case of
constants you cannot during the
computation you cannot really change
these values so for example if you want
to change the value of b from 3 to 5 or
any other number it is not possible so
that is the meaning of constant all
right so then we have variables so
variables we are all familiar with what
are variables whenever we use
programming we use variables so this is
pretty much the same this is the way you
define variables tf dot variable now one
thing you need to note is this is the
only type in which we have v capital
okay constant has c a small c and
placeholder as small p but variable as
capital v and tf.variable and then you
give the a value and then you can
specify what is the type and then you
can use the variable change the variable
at any point in time with a different
value and so on you can update the
variable and so on so we will see all of
this in the code i will illustrate how a
variable is defined and how it can be
changed whereas a constant cannot be
changed and so on and so forth and then
we have placeholders placeholders are
really a special type and this may be
something completely new for many of us
who have been doing programming but in
tensorflow this is a completely new
concept so this is very important to
understand this placeholders are like
variables but only thing is that they
are used for feeding the data from
outside so typically when you are
performing some computations you need to
load data from a file or from an image
file or from a csv file or whatever so
there is a provision with the special
kind of variables which can be fed in a
regular basis because the reason one of
the reasons for having this kind of
provision is that if you get the entire
input in one shot typically it may be
very difficult to handle memory and so
on so i think that was the reason they
came up with this mechanism where you
can feed in patches and there is a
certain way of populating the
placeholder we call this feed dig field
underscore dick and this is a parameter
name by the way and you feed the
placeholders right that is the meaning
here so there is a certain way of
feeding the placeholders and we will
again see this in the example code as we
move forward okay so there are three
types one is the constant which cannot
be changed once you assign a value then
you have variables which are like normal
variables we are all familiar with and
then you have placeholders this is
primarily for feeding data from usually
from outside but of course you can also
for temporary testing purpose you can
feed within the program as well but
primarily the purpose of a placeholder
is to get data from outside so all right
so those were the constants variables
and placeholders that is how you
handle data within the tensorflow
program and then you create a graph and
once you create a graph then you have
what is known as a session and then you
create a session object and you create a
session and then you run a particular
computation or a node or an operation
and so typically what you need to do is
every variable or a computation that you
perform is like an operation or a node
within a graph so initially the graph
will be what is known as the default
graph the moment you create a tensorflow
object or tf this tf here you see this
is the tensorflow object and again in
the code when we go into the code it
will become much easier to understand so
when you create a tensorflow object
there is like a default graph which
doesn't have any operations no nodes or
anything like that so it's like a clean
slate the moment you
assign variables or constants or
placeholders each of them is in
tensorflow terms it is known as an
operation again you need to get familiar
with these terms and they are not very
intuitive this is not really an
operation you're just creating a
constant or a variable but and this c is
equal to a into b would traditionally or
would intuitively be an operation here
you're actually performing an operation
but in tensorflow terms each of these
everything is an operation so if you're
creating a constant that is an operation
another constant or variable that's an
operation so you can actually run each
of these and they are also known as
referred to as nodes and when you're in
your session you will actually run each
of these you can potentially run each of
these nodes okay so a typical example
would look like this so you have two
constants created a is equal to
tf.constant its value is 5 b is equal to
this and then you say c is equal to a
into b and then you create a session now
remember all this you're just creating a
graph at this point no execution has
happened all right so only at this point
once you create a session and then you
say session or says dot run c is when
actually this whole thing will get
executed all right so that is a
different way of programming compared to
our traditional way of writing programs
so you need to get used to this new
format and when we look at the code as
we move forward and when we look in the
jupyter notebook it will become much
easier probably to understand this
rather than in the slide so these are
the slides showing the code but what we
can do is go straight into the
lab and take a look at the various
examples that are there and starting
from the very basic one how you create
variables and so these are some of the
slides that are showing so this is about
how to create variables how to create
constants and the variables or constants
can also be strings so this is like our
first hello world program and we will
talk about placeholders how to define a
placeholder and how to execute and
populate the placeholder values into
placeholder we will see these examples
in the lab actually i will run the code
and
we will also perform a small computation
of adding and multiplying these
variables and
we will in the end we will take up a use
case implementation using tensorflow so
let's first go and see those examples
and then come back and i'll explain this
use case and then we will execute the
use case in the lab so let's go and
check our lab okay so i'm in the jupiter
notebook environment and this is one of
the development environments we can use
this is regular python
anytime you do python programming we use
chiptune notebook or there are rather of
course there are other ways of using
other tools like pycharm and so on but
for this particular tutorial i'm
comfortable using jupyter notebook so i
will show you in jupyter notebook so
this is the very basic example to
demonstrate how to create variables and
constants and placeholders and what is
the difference between them how they
behave and so on and as i mentioned the
assumption here is that you know at
least some basic python programming or
some programming language so at least
you understand the code here and first
two pieces of code you will not need
machine learning background but when we
do the use case of the case study there
it is expected that you know at least
some basic machine learning concepts so
in case you need to brush up the machine
learning part you may have to do that
before you go to the third one but here
just at least some idea of programming
will be sufficient so what are we doing
here in this particular line or in this
particular cell we are importing
tensorflow it is uh as i mentioned it is
a library so we are importing tensorflow
and we are calling it tf so this is just
a name you can give it any name but it
is very common and everywhere wherever
tensorflow programming is done it is
always named as tf but you can name
anything actually okay so this will
import the tensorflow into my session
now this is the way to create a variable
so let's start by creating a variable
and this is the name of my variable i'm
starting by giving a name called 0 and i
say 0 is equal to tf dot variable and
then i'm giving the value of the
variable here so this is the very basic
way and the simplest way to create a
variable we will see a little later
there are other formats as well but the
bare minimum way of creating a variable
is this so i'm creating a variable by
the name zero and as i mentioned you
need to pay attention to the capital v
here in case of variable it is a capital
v uppercase constant and placeholders
are
lower case now i'm creating a constant
then the constant i'm naming it as 1 and
the way to create a constant is tf dot
constant and then you give the value of
the constant so the value of the
variable here is 0 and the value of
constant here is 1. and again constant
you can also have additional parameters
like a name and so on probably you must
have seen in other tutorials or in other
places where the code is written but the
basic format to construct to create a
constant is this this is sufficient to
create a constant so i created one
variable and one constant now what else
can we do again here there is no real
execution happening we are just building
a graph we have not yet executed any
tensorflow code we are building a graph
and i will show you how the graph looks
as well first let us understand the
constants and variables and so on and
then i will show you how the graph is
generated and so on so what i want to do
here is i want to add 0 and 1 and put it
into a new variable called new value so
what i do here tensorflow offers these
methods like add assign multiply or you
have matrix multiplication matmul and so
on right so i will use one of those
methods which is tf dot add and then
pass these two as parameters so we can
add a variable and a constant there are
no restrictions on that so this is a
variable and this is a constant so if i
do this it will be okay i did not
execute this code so it is giving an
error now we are good okay so what it
has done is new value will be equal to
tf dot add 0 1 so then we have one
variable and one constant now let's say
i want to change the value of the
variable because that is possible right
so we want to change the value of the
variable to something some new value so
we have in this case new value has one
because we added a zero and a one so new
value has one now i want to assign this
to this originally what we called as
zero so i will call that as update is
equal to tf dot assign so assign is
basically changing the value so that's
what we we're going to do here now it
has not complained we'll just say fine
right there are no issues now let us try
this something similar with this 1 as
well so 0 is a variable so we were able
to change the value and we will in a
little while we will see what exactly
those values are but before doing that
now let's say i will uncomment this part
and i want to do something similar for
my constant right 1 is a constant now i
want to let's say change the value of
the constant and make that also
something different okay so if i execute
this piece of code it will give an error
now again the error message may not be
very intuitive this doesn't say that you
cannot do this for a constant it will
just say tensor object has no attribute
assign now that sometimes may be
confusing especially when you are
starting but the meaning here is that
one is a constant and you're trying to
modify the constant so it will not allow
that's the reason it is complaining so
let's put that back in the comment and
okay so that is done so only variables
you can modify now what you have to do
let's skip this piece of code i'll come
back to this in a bit
but let's say we start by creating you
remember i told you we need to create a
session so the way to create a session
there are a couple of ways of creating a
session but this is for beginners this
is the easiest way all you need to do is
assign a variable called says or you can
give any name and that is equal to tf
dot session that is the session method
here and you create a session object by
the name says now what i'll do is i'll
skip this as well i there is a purpose
behind that now let's go ahead and run
this piece of particular operation
remember i mentioned that everything you
need to run so as of now the code has
not really got executed tensorflow code
has not got executed you only created
the graph so only when you
run through the session is when that
actually the program gets executed so
when you do this now you see observe
that it is giving an error okay the
reason behind that is remember we skip
these two lines of code for variables
okay this and then this now this is
something
very very important to observe if you
have variables in your code what i mean
by that is let's say you are not using
variables but you have only constants
and placeholders then this will not
complain and you will not get this error
but in our case we also have variable so
whenever you have variables in that case
you need to do an initialization and
this is just a
standard code there is nothing that we
need to add or modify or anything like
that this is a standard piece of code
you create this name of course can be
anything you can give us any name but
this global variables initializer is
what you need to call tf.global
variables initializer this will kind of
initialize all the variables that you
may be using and then again remember
this doesn't execute anything right so
all you're doing here is you're creating
an operation but in order to run that
operation you need to also run this
known as run init underscore op so this
operation you need to run after creating
the session all right so we executed
this now let us execute this and now
when i run this piece of code it will
run successfully okay i hope you
observed that so it is whenever you use
variables these two lines of code one is
the operation you need to create an
operation for saying global variables
initializer and then you need to run
before running anything else you need to
do a session.run this operation okay
again only if you're using
variables of course you invariably in
all your programs you will use variables
you cannot just write a program with
constants and placeholders so you can
pretty much assume that this has to be
there in pretty much all the programs
now again why
this has not been taken care of in the
library that's a different question but
you need to keep in mind and always
remember
if you don't do this for whatever reason
if you're forgotten you will get an
error and the error won't be intuitive
so you need to remember this that this
could be because of the variables okay
good so we have seen how to create a
constant and we have seen how to create
a variable and we have seen that you
cannot modify or update a constant and
we have also seen if you have variables
that you need to execute or have these
two lines of code to initialize the
variables and then we have seen that
after creating a graph how to run the
graph in a session and i will show you a
little bit more in detail how exactly
the graph gets created and how it gets
executed but this was the first very
quick code on creating variables and
constants now we will keep going and
we will also show you or i will show you
the placeholders but before that one
more small piece of code so this is how
you write a for loop okay so we are
saying five times you run this piece of
code now like any python program this is
nothing different so you have a for loop
and this is indented that's the reason
and therefore you say session.run update
so this will run five times and it will
get printed that's all so update will
run for five times each time it will
come and do this particular operation
that's all we are we are asking the
system to do so let me just run that and
show you let me yeah so it will okay so
it has done five times
one that's four it is basically adding
if you recall it starts from zero it
adds one to zero then one to one one to
two and so on so it's nothing but it is
generating five numbers one two three
four five that's it okay so then
you can also have your constants as
strings for example so you can also work
in a similar way you can work with
string so most of the computation
happens
mainly on numerical values so we
normally hand handle numbers but there
will be situations where you may have to
handle strings
as well or text as well so this is an
example of text operation so you can
similar to numbers you just create
strings or store in constants instead of
a number you say hello is equal to
tf.constant and then you assign the
string that you want it to be assigned
and then the next one is one more string
which is for world and then you say add
these two so it is nothing but
concatenation of these two words hello
and
world so we will do that and remember
this is only creation of the graph right
so in order to actually execute this
graph you need to run the session now
you need to keep in mind we don't have
to create the session once again because
once you create a session till you close
the session it remains valid okay so we
have created this session here now till
you say says dot close it will remain
for you so that's why we did not create
one more so we are just reusing that
session says dot run hello world so in
this hello world what is the operation
that we are doing here the operation is
add these two concatenate these two so
if i
run this it will print hello world okay
now that's string operation now we will
take a look at placeholders so this is
slightly more complicated and something
new even for people who have been
writing programs so but i'll just
explain it with uh with a quick example
first of all how do you declare or
create a placeholder you just do
tf.placeholder and the p is lower case
only in case of variables the v is upper
case but otherwise constant and place
one as it is lowercase and you just say
because as i mentioned this is a
placeholder it doesn't have any value so
you unlike a constant or your variable
you can't usually you will not specify
any value you just say what type of
placeholder you want and very often most
of the cases it is a floating point so
we just say placeholder of type float32
so this tf dot float32 tells the system
that it is a floating point okay and
then so let me just run this and then
you can do some or define some
computation like for example b is equal
to a into 2. now remember here right now
a has no value but what we are saying
here is at any point later on when a
gets some value then b should be equal
to twice the value of a that's all we
are saying here okay and also as i've
mentioned earlier we are not yet
executing anything we are just creating
the graph here okay so now you have that
now how do you feed the value or
populate the placeholder there is a
certain syntax in which you can populate
the placeholder and you do that using
what is known as a dictionary you're all
probably familiar those with python
especially must be familiar with the
dictionaries so you need to create a
dictionary and then pass that
in order to feed the placeholder so in
this particular example if i want to run
something if i want to calculate or
compute b obviously i need to feed the
value of a so the value of a i'm feeding
using this dictionary and i'm saying
that a is equal to 3. now there are
multiple ways of populating the value of
a because it typically this won't be
just a single a scalar value like in
this case right remember scalar so it's
just one value one number typically it
would be a vector or or a tensor very
often it is a tensor so we will see step
by step so we can start with the very
basic example where a can be a scalar so
in this case a is equal to 3 that's what
we are saying feed underscore dict in
this case feed underscore dick is the
name of a variable by the way so you
can't give anything else here so if you
just say feed is equal to this it will
give you an error all right so keep that
in mind either you specify feed
underscore dick is equal to and give the
dictionary pass the dictionary or you
straight away like in this case this is
another format so let's see first let me
execute this it has given six okay i
think let me see if i can clear out this
particular cell so it becomes easier to
understand okay so it is giving you six
let me do that once again clear out this
and then okay and let me change the
format so this is one way of doing it
another way is you don't even have to
specify the name of this parameter feed
underscore dict you just pass the
dictionary and it will
execute okay but typically this makes
the code readable so that's the reason
most of the places whenever you find
tensorflow code you will see that they
explicitly mention feed underscore date
so that the code is readable otherwise
it can get confusing so i will also
comment this and retain the other format
okay so i hope it's clear so what we are
doing here we are running the operation
b and what exactly is b b is twice a a
into two so therefore what we are doing
and a has not been
doesn't have any value out here right so
that's why we are feeding the value of a
and then the operation gets completed so
a gets a value of 3
and then it gets multiplied by 2 because
that's what we said here therefore b
gets a value of 6 and that's what is
being fed into result and that's what is
getting printed here okay now as i
mentioned a need not be just a scalar
value it can be a vector with a
multi-dimension
array and so on and so forth so let's
start showing you examples of that again
let me just clear out the outputs let me
clear this and let me also clear this
for now okay you can also do before
running up this you could we could also
do clear all output all output clear it
will clear everything but that will
we'll have to start all over again so i
am just doing individually all right so
in this example we are taking a one
dimension array where rank is equal to
one and i am feeding three four five now
let us see what happens if i run this
right as you can imagine it gets
multiplied each number gets multiplied
so the result is 6 8 10 okay now as i
said it can get more complicated now
let's say this is a multi-dimensional
vector so if you what happens if you
feed this okay so as you can see this is
pretty complicated now but if you feed
this again all you're doing is uh there
is okay there is a slight change here
again you can also
create your dictionary outside and feed
that here you don't have to directly do
it here like in this case you see there
are variations of the exact syntax in
the way you write it right so there is a
slight variation so in this case you are
creating the dictionary straight away
here kind of inline but here you created
the dictionary separately because it is
more complicated and then you are
passing that dictionary here so i said
dictionary is equal to a and then i am
saying this is what should be the value
of a this is and i'm feeding that and
then i'm
using directly that dictionary here okay
so this is equivalent to putting this
code here right so if we execute this
what happens same so you get because a
was a let's say this is a
three by
four by two right so that is one yeah
three by four by two right so you see
here this is a multi-dimensional array
so you feed that and the values you see
here it is one two three it became two
four six four five six became eight ten
twelve seven eight nine became fourteen
sixteen eighteen and so on and so forth
okay i hope now you got an idea about
placeholders and in real life what
happens is you typically won't create
these dictionaries manually in since
this is a quick demo we did this you
will actually
read the data into this dictionary and
then you feed that when you're doing the
computation okay so it could be a csv
file or it could be a image file so
input is basically
read and fed in
usually it is also done in patches so
you don't read the entire thing because
they can be large amount of data so that
is the idea behind having these
placeholders and the way we feed these
placeholders there is a provision that
is a deliberately that has been made a
provision for
this kind of getting data into the
program in chunks okay now in this
particular example we will close the
session here and then i will show you
what is the other way of creating a
session right so now if i close the
session here now if i try to do anything
with the session it will give us an
error so i will probably not do that
right now now there is another way or
another format and this is a very common
way of using the session but i didn't
want to start off with this because this
could get a little confusing the a
simpler way was to create session saying
says is equal to tf.session but
typically you will do it in what is
known as a with block this is a very
common way of creating session so once
you have the graph you would execute the
graph in a session using a width block
and this is the syntax so you say with
df dot session assess all right and then
you put all your code here so what will
happen is you don't have to explicitly
close the session the moment this width
block gets
completed the session gets closed okay
so let's just take a quick look at this
example now if i
let me clear this current output be
clear okay so this is the hello world
example a little bit earlier we did that
so i'm doing
with tf.session assessment result is
equal to says dot run hello plus world
and then i say print result okay so
within this with block i am doing all my
computation and this gets executed now
let's say i try to run remember i
created a session here now if i want to
let's say do something like run sesh dot
run a it is giving an error because the
session is no longer valid
right so you cannot either you have to
run this if you want to run this you
have to run this in this with block
or you shouldn't have closed the session
here right you remember this we said
session.close so since we have closed
the session there is no active session
therefore it is giving an error okay now
there is a third way of creating a
session but for now i will skip it
because that is very very specific to
the notebooks and and so on so we will
just avoid it you start with for
beginners i think the best way is to
start with creating a separate session
and then writing your code and then
closing your session now of course
remember if you don't do this part says
dot close it will not give any error or
anything like that only thing is that
it's a good practice and your resources
will get released otherwise
if you do multiple of these programs if
they are running then your resources
will get blocked that's the only thing
and to start with this it is simpler to
do it this way so initially when you're
doing you start with this but as you
move forward as you become familiar with
tensorflow programming i would recommend
all of you to get into this model most
of the programming tensorflow
programming is done like this with
df.sessions okay all right so that was
one book or one page of a code that we
have done explaining about variables
constants and placeholders now let me
explain how the graph works so in this
example we are going to see how the
graph is created how the graph gets
executed and so on okay now that we got
a understanding of constants and
variables and placeholders okay so we
will start as usual by importing our
library and as i said whenever you
create a tf or tensorflow object there
will be what is known as a default graph
and you can get a handle of that by
saying get default graph so let's do
that and you can display the operations
remember every node in the graph is
considered as an operation right so as
of now as you can see
we have not done anything we have not
created a constant or variable or
nothing right so there was there is no
operation so by the way let's do one
thing let's start with the
all output clear so that
i don't have to again do individually so
we i'll just run these two lines of code
okay now so yeah so we have the default
graph and as of now there are no
operations so there is a method called
get underscore operations which will
kind of display or show what are the
various operations that have been
performed on the graph so as i said to
start with they have no operations being
performed so when i try to display it's
empty there are no nothing is there no
operations okay now let's see what
happens when we slowly step by step
start writing or building the graph so
my first step may be to create a
constant okay remember in the previous
example i have shown you how to create a
constant in the most simple or the
simplest way which is like constant and
then the number right now a small
extension of that is you can actually
give a name to your constant now again
this need not be the same i can say a is
equal to name and xyz i can give
anything here okay this is just for your
reference but here for simplicity
because there is a purpose why i am
using the same name as the name of the
variable and there are other reasons as
well why you would give a name again to
a constant or a variable this is again
useful when we are using what is known
as tensorboard otherwise it doesn't have
much value this additional name doesn't
have much value in this our case also we
will be seeing the graph and that's why
i am using this but otherwise this
having additionally a name usually
doesn't add much value all right so
let's create a constant
i created a constant now let us see
what's going on in the graph so i will
just say operations is equal to get
operations and if you see here now
you remember here it was blank now you
see the first operation is showing up
and this a that's the reason i put here
so it is showing as a and it says that
okay you have performed an operation
and there is a constant you have created
a constant okay all right so let's move
on let's say we want to create a second
constant
and this is b so if i see what does what
are the operations list of operations
that have been performed you see here
there are two of them so you have
operation a which is a constant then you
have an operation b another constant you
recall we in the term operation here is
not very intuitive right so we are just
creating constants or numbers or
variables and it is saying it's an
operation but that's that's a
terminology in tensorflow everything is
an operation here okay all right so then
what else let's say i want to create a
third operation
and that is basically adding which is
this is a real operation in normal sense
as well so let's say i'm creating c
which is um adding a and b and the c
value obviously will be a plus b
okay now if we want to see what is in c
and we say c you see here it is not
showing
it just says it is a tensor
and it is of type in 32 right because
we have not executed the graph we are
still only building the graph i hope
this makes it easy to understand okay so
we are just building the graph we have
till we do remember till we do a session
and run a particular operation you're
not actually executing anything okay
you're just building the graph all right
so now let us see what are the
operations we have done a b and now c so
you will see there are three of them a b
and c okay now let's do
one more operation which is d
and here i am doing multiplication
remember we did a tf dot add now i'll do
tf.multiply and i'm multiplying a and b
and i'm calling this operation as d so a
has
i think 10 and b has 20 so d will be
actually 200 when we execute it right
now it is just a tensor and it is of
shape in 32 okay and once again we can
see what are the operations abcd and
let's do one last operation here which
is e which is once again multiplication
of c and d now that c has 30 which is a
plus b and d has 200 which is a into b
so now c into d will be 30 into 200
which is which is equal to
6000 but as we have seen earlier that
multiplication will not happen right now
so now you have built a fairly simple
but operation graph which consists of
a b c d e one two three four five
operations okay so you built a small
it's not a very complicated one but a
simple graph now you need to execute
these operations so what you need to do
you need to create a session okay so
says dot tf is equal to session and then
you can run these session
print says dot run e now am i missing
something do i have to initialize the
variables that's a question for you
thing can tell me do i have to
initialize the variables that remember i
ran one piece of code i think you must
have got the answer i don't have to
because i am just using all constants
here i have not used any variable here
right so i don't have to write execute
that piece of code to initialize the
variables so i can just create a session
and run any of the operations that i
want to run so in this case i am running
session e operation e right this
operation e now i can actually run
individually instead of doing directly e
i could have run only a or i could have
run b and so on and so forth but in this
case i have run e which in turn will do
all the required computations which is
for example assigning the value to a and
b and c doing the multiplication and so
on all those operations will be
performed which are required to do the
computation of e okay now there is a
small piece of code that you can use to
find out what are the various operations
that are there in this particular graph
in this case of course it was very easy
very straightforward i have created
abcde but in normal programming in real
life this can sometimes help to see
how
what is there in your graph what kind of
operations are going on in your graph so
you can write this piece of code and it
may sometimes help debugging as well
okay all right so i finished my session
what do we have to do we need to close
the session right because i did not use
the width block so i need to close the
session as a good practice so i close
the session good so that's how the graph
works
i hope it was helpful in understanding
how variables and constants and
placeholders are created in the previous
example we saw and how exactly you
create a graph and then you actually
execute that graph that's the way
tensorflow program works that's the
structure of tensorflow program okay so
now that we understood the structure of
tensorflow programming let's take an
example and a classification example and
take some real
data from from outside external data csv
file and
try to solve a classification problem
for that let's first go back to the
slides and understand what is the
problem statement and then we will come
back okay so what is the case here we
have some census data and which has all
these features or variables like um the
age of a person
what class work class what is his
education what is his marital status
gender and so on and so forth so there
are a bunch of a bunch of features that
are available and
we have to basically classify or not
classify we have to build a model for
classifying whether the income of this
person is above 50k
or below 50k okay so there is actually a
label data available we will then try to
build a model and then see what is the
accuracy so that this is a typical
machine learning problem actually but as
i said tensorflow can be used for doing
machine learning as well so we will as a
simple example we will take uh machine
learning so this is how the high level
the code looks and in tensorflow
programming we also take a help of
regular python
libraries like for example
it could be numpy or it could be
scikit-learn or it could be pandas in
this case and because before you
actually develop or before you train
your model create your model you need to
prepare the data into a certain format
and sometimes if you're doing machine
learning activity you all are familiar
those familiar with machine learning
will know you need to split your data
into training and test data sets so all
that can be done using regular
non-tensorflow libraries right so these
are like regular python libraries and
cyclic learn and so on so we use that
and then prepare the data and then use
tensorflow for performing either the
machine learning or deep learning
activity now so what is the advantage of
using tensorflow the main advantage is
that tensorflow offers high level apis
right we talked about that so in this
case we will be using i'll explain what
is in the slide but before that i wanted
to just show you what is the api that we
will be using so we will be using the
estimator api we will be using the
estimator api to create a classifier
what is known as a linear classifier now
in order to do that you need to prepare
the data and you need to prepare the
data into a certain structure or format
and the api itself needs to be fed in a
certain way so that is exactly what we
are doing before we get into the regular
tensorflow code okay so these slides
will quickly show you what exactly is
happening but i will take you into
jupiter notebook and run that code and
show you so here we are importing the
data the data is the name of the file is
census underscore data.csv it's a csv
file and then there is uh
income bracket is one of the columns
which basically is our target that is
what is used that is the label rather
but this doesn't have numeric values so
it has the income so
we need to convert that into binary
values either 0 or 1. so that's what we
are doing here and then we are splitting
using scikit-learn we are doing
splitting of the data into test and
training right so this is a standard
scikit-learn people some of you who are
familiar with machine traditional
machine learning and you have done
machine learning in python using scikit
learn will immediately recognize this
this is a sk learning scikit learn and
there is a readily available method to
split the data into training and test
that's what we are doing here and
then you need to create what is known as
feature columns and input functions
before you can call the api estimator
api that's what we are doing here and
data and also there is there are
different ways of creating the feature
columns for
numeric values and for categorical
values or rather for continuous values
and categorical values okay so that's
what has been
two types we are doing here
we will see again in the code as well
and
then you create your model so this is
basically model is equal to df.estimator
linear classifier and then you're
feeding the feature columns and also
subsequently you will call the training
by passing the input function and you
specify how many iterations to be done
for the training process and again this
is all typical machine learning process
so there is nothing specific for
tensorflow here and then you evaluate
your model because this is
classification model so you can again
take help of the scikit-learn to test
the accuracy and get the report
evaluation perform the evaluation and
get the report like this one right so
this is the classification report and
you will see what is the precision
recall f1 score and so on again this is
a standard machine learning process all
right so that's pretty much as far as
the code here is concerned once again
let me take you into our
lab and
we will get started with this particular
code now let me clear out the outputs so
that you can step by step you can see
the output so this is our data and
we will actually this is just a display
here the code starts from here so before
when we start with our tensorflow part
of it as i mentioned we now remember in
the previous examples the data was kind
of cooked up internally we created some
data and we were using it right the
constant variables and so on here is a
real life example so you are actually
getting data from outside so you know
before we get into tensorflow this is
actually regular python code so we are
using pandas for example to create our
data frame so we will import pandas and
then we will basically read our file
into a pandas data frame and this is how
the data
looks right and if you do a head it will
give you about six
readings or observations five or six
observations and then you can take a
look at how your data is looking so for
example you have age work class
education and so on and so forth
and you see here this last column income
underscore bracket it says whether the
income is greater than 50k or less than
50k so this cannot be
understood or this cannot be fed into
our
model or
you know so that's the reason we need to
convert this this will not be understood
right so this needs to be converted
saying okay maybe less than 50 k is 0
and greater than 50 k is 1 so that
conversion needs to be done before we
feed it into our model so that's what we
are going to do as we move forward so
this is the code for doing that okay so
we take this and then we define a
function
and then we run that function so now we
have wherever it is
less than 50 k
it will have 0 and greater than 50 50k
it will have one so we have now updated
the data then the next part is to split
our data into training and test data set
so how are we going to do that we again
will take the standard python library
which is scikit-learn sk-learn library
and
we use an existing
function there which is a train test
split and what we are doing here is
basically splitting the data into i'm
sorry i need to run this
and then this
okay sorry about that so
once i run this what is what are we
doing here again those are familiar with
scikit learn will immediately recognize
i am splitting this into test and train
i'm saying test size is 30 so 30 of the
data should go into test and training
should have 70 percent okay so that's
all we are doing point 3 indicates 30
percent so you can again this can be
individual preferences some people do it
like 50 50 some people 20 80 and in our
case we are doing
70 30. so training is 70 and test is 30.
okay all right so
we have so far we've been doing regular
non-tensorflow stuff so preparing the
data so that we can now use for
tensorflow and in tensorflow what we are
doing is we will be using the api called
estimator now estimator in order to call
estimator you need to prepare what is
known as feature columns so feature
columns have to be in a certain format
basically it is nothing but the columns
we have to put them in a certain format
and then when we are calling the the
training we need to pass what is known
as an input function again a certain way
in which you need to pass that function
so that is what we need to do before we
create the model and run the model for
training so the next few lines will be
doing that quick look at before we even
get in once again into the
tensorflow code so this is just showing
us what are the various columns names of
the columns of this data okay so that is
what is uh shown here and this is more
for when i was writing the code i could
copy paste from here that's the reason i
this line of code is there instead of
typing in these values okay good so now
is where the actual tensorflow action
starts so i import tensorflow and now i
will use this feature column
functionality to create my feature
columns and there is a certain construct
how you create the feature columns again
probably the details of that is out of
scope here but just that you need to
know that we need to create feature
columns and the way you create feature
columns for continuous values and for
categorical values is slightly different
and that's the reason you have two
different blocks okay so for categorical
values you need to use what is known as
tf dot feature column dot categorical
column with vocabulary list and again
within this again there are two ways in
which you can create for categorical
values one is a vocabulary list where
you know
how many types are there so for example
gender column can have only male and
female so in such a case if there are
let's say a finite number of values for
a given column then you use a column
with vocabulary list okay so and then
you say what is the name of the column
and what are the possible values so in
this case male and female now there will
be situations where the the values that
this column can have
okay first of all it is a categorical
column that means it can have names or
some non-numerical values but the number
of values is probably unknown or
undefined so for example occupation now
occupation can have any value it can be
self-employed it can be software
professional bank a teacher doctor so so
many possibilities are there and we
don't know in the given data how many
occupations have been listed right so
that is where you use what is known as
categorical column with hash bucket and
you specify the hash bucket size so what
it what this says is there can be a
maximum of thousand such values so
typically you give a safe number safely
large number so that you don't run out
of these number of occupations so i
think thousand is a safe number i don't
think there will be more than thousand
occupations in a given data so that's
the idea behind it but that's a judgment
call we need to take what should be the
size of this bucket size right hash
bucket size so these are two different
types for categorical values for
creating the feature column so we will
execute this for all the categorical
columns obviously you need to know the
type of the columns and that is where if
you see right at the beginning this
information was provided what is the
data type and you see here the column
name and what whether it is continuous
or categorical this information is
provided in the census data wherever we
pick this census data from by the way
this was picked from online from a
government website and we stored locally
so on that website it is mentioned the
details of this data were mentioned and
they have mentioned whether each of
these columns is categorical or
continuous so that information we have
to use and we have to create feature
columns using this categorical method
for the categorical type of columns and
then for numeric or continuous values
you just use
what is known as feature column dot
numeric column okay so these are all
continuous or numeric values like age
education number capital gain capital
loss hours per work these are all
numerical values or continuous values
right so you just say tf.feature
underscore column dot numeric underscore
column and then give the name of the
column so once you do that i think i
have executed the previous one yeah this
one now so your feature columns are
ready and you need to basically create a
vector of all these columns and we call
that as feet
underscore calls which is which is like
a short form for feature columns now as
you have seen i've mentioned earlier
also there are two things that are
needed one is the feature columns and
another is the input function so feature
columns to first create the model and
then to train the model you need to
create an input function so now we have
the feature columns ready next is to
create an input function and there is a
certain way in which you need to
this construct is pretty much very
common construct so we will use that so
the input function takes these x and y
values for training and tests you
remember these are the x strain is the x
values of the training data set and y
train is the labels of the training data
set so that's what we are using here
extreme y train and then we specify what
is the batch size batch size you
remember i mentioned this is what will
say how many records need to be read
each time right so typically in when we
are doing the training process
we don't get the entire data in one shot
we do it in batches so what size you
specify here number of epochs in this
case we just say none but number of
epochs is again probably the definition
is not required here but at a very high
level how many times the entire data has
to be passed through the model right so
if you have thousand records and you
pass all the thousand records
three times for training purpose then
you call that as three epochs right so
there is a difference between the batch
size and epochs so when let's say we
have thousand records and you are saying
batch size is hundred that means there
will be ten batches right so if you take
10 batches then that is one epoch gets
completed okay then you the training
obviously doesn't get completed in one
round okay so you need to pass this data
again maybe a second time or a third
time till you get the right accuracy
that is known as epochs okay again if
you need more details about this you may
have to go through the machine learning
tutorial i think it becomes much clearer
okay so you have your input function as
well let's execute that okay and now we
are ready to create the use the api
right so what will we do we will create
the linear classifier using
tf.estimator.linearclassifier
and
this guy needs feature columns right so
that's why we created we did all that so
much of
manipulations to create this feature
columns so we have feature columns so we
pass that and we create our model there
may be a few warnings don't worry about
that so we will just ignore that and now
we use that model and we actually what
we did is we created an instance of the
model we have not really run anything we
just created a instance of the model now
we will create the node for training so
model.train and this needs the input
function remember we we created the
input function so we need to pass the
input function and then we say
the steps is now telling how many
iterations this training
has to be run so we are saying 5 000 and
this may be it will probably take a
little long so we will okay but that's
fine i think we will leave it 5000.
sometimes if you have probably a less
powerful machine you can cut it down to
maybe thousand or something like that
but in this case i have a fairly
powerful system so i think it shouldn't
take much long let's uh go ahead and
give a couple of minutes for it to get
over okay so let us go back yeah i think
this is done you see here the the
hourglass has
disappeared that means this computation
is done yes okay this is done right
saving checkpoint for 5000 that means it
is done so training is done so now what
we have to do we need to do the
evaluation so
again this is a standard machine
learning method so
methodology rather so training has been
done with the training data set now you
need to evaluate using your test data
set so that's what we are doing here for
example you see here x underscore test
is your the test data set remember we
used scikit-learn to split the data into
training and test data set so x
underscore test and a quick question why
are we not using y underscore test here
like we did in case of uh training
obviously we are expecting the model to
predict the values y values right so
that's why we don't pass the y values
here all right so let's execute this for
doing the evaluation all right and then
we
put them in a proper format because the
output doesn't come out in a proper
format so we put it in a list format and
then we can just check yeah so this is
done and
we can check what is the first element
in this what is the probabilities and so
on so it's just
a quick way to see if the values are
there or not you can take any value here
right any element here all right now
that the testing is done what we need to
do again we will probably put them in
some kind of this is more of a
formatting thing we will just uh
run through quickly and then we will use
once again scikit-learn for finding out
the accuracy and so on because
scikit-learn offers what is known as a
classification report functionality so
we will use that
and find out how well our model has
performed so you see here again people
with
machine learning background will be
immediately able to recognize this so it
gives us what is the precision what is
the recall and f1 score
this is pretty much like you're getting
like almost 85 percent accuracy which is
pretty okay and
there are other ways to increase the
accuracy for example you can run the
training for more iterations that is one
way get more data and so on and so forth
or user this is a linear classifier we
could you have used a non-linear
classifier and so on so again multiple
ways of doing it to increase the
accuracy but the idea here was to
quickly show you a piece of
tensorflow code and that's what we have
done here diabetic retinopathy is a
condition which can lead to blindness
and it is caused as the name suggests
due to diabetes and there are ways to
detect this early on and maybe cure it
and prevent blindness so how can we do
something like that there is research
going on and one of the techniques used
as deep learning which is a part of
neural networks and which is a part of
artificial intelligence the way it works
is hundreds of thousands of images known
as fundus images are sent to the neural
network and the neural network is
trained with this labeled information
now these images we know whether they
are good or they are defective or there
is a disease in this eye or there is no
disease so that labeling is done this
labeled information is fed to the neural
network the neural network uses deep
learning and it will learn to detect if
this from the image to find out if this
disease exists so that when a new image
is fed it will be able to identify
whether the eye is healthy or diseased
now let's take a simple example of a
linear regression how it works in
tensorflow this is a small code example
so if you want to perform a linear
regression where obviously the model
will be y is equal to mx plus b and with
the given data you want to obviously
come up with the values of m and b which
are the coefficients right so let's say
we want to do something like this to
start with you can use again we use
python here so the traditional python
libraries like numpy and pandas all of
that is available to us we can use them
along with our tensorflow library
because the tensorflow is nothing but
one of the libraries okay let's say we
create some random data test data or
artificial data and uh this is how you
create a linearly separated or evenly
separated uh random values right lid
spaces basically you create random
values between 0 and 10 and 10 random
values and they are linearly or evenly
distributed that's what we are doing
here and we are adding some to give it a
little flavor of
realness we are adding some random
values as well okay so that is what we
are doing here so this is how the data
looks x underscore data which is our
independent variables and similarly we
are creating some random values of
dependent variable as well right y
underscore label is our dependent
variable so if we do this and then if we
plot this is how our data looks right so
if we did not add these
randomness then you would have actually
got the all the dots in a straight line
so we don't want that so that's the
reason we are adding the randomness as
well so this is how it looks now we want
to find the best fit for this all right
and again some of you are not familiar
with the machine learning concepts of
linear regression and so on you may want
to watch some of our other videos where
we have created basics of machine
learning and so on the concept of linear
regression all the algorithms are
explained there in detail but very
briefly here what is a linear regression
linear regression is the best fit so you
need to come up with an equation of a
line which will basically let's say pass
through these data points in such a way
that the error is very minimal right so
the line obviously will not pass through
all the data points but it will lie
somewhere in between and when you
calculate error it will be minimum
that's the idea of training this okay so
how do we do it in using tensorflow so
we assign some variables so m is a
variable and b is another variable
remember this is how we create these
variables right so tf dot variable tf
because we are creating variables by the
way because they they cannot be
constants it cannot the values cannot be
fixed and why are these values 0.39 and
0.2 again these are randomly generated
we just use a numpy random function and
we generated this it can be anything
initially you can give anything 0 also
can be given but just to keep it
realistic we actually create some random
numbers and assign them those values
okay then we find out what is known as
the cost function what is the cost
function cost function is nothing but
the error between the actual value and
the calculated value so with the given
values of x if we feed to this model it
will calculate based on the value of m
at any given point in time it will
create what is known as the predicted
value which is y underscore hat so in
this case when the first run it will be
0.39 into whatever is the value of x
plus 0.2 okay and remember these values
will change that's why i have given as
variable they will not be constant and
the whole training process is to change
these values and then come up at the end
with some set of values of m and b such
that if you use that in this equation of
m x plus b then the errors will be
minimum that is the idea behind linear
regression again this is a little
difficult to explain here but if you
actually watch our video on linear
regression it will probably become more
clear so here the assumption is that you
are familiar with linear regression okay
so so the error obviously will be the
difference between the calculated value
and the actual value as we all know we
square that so this indicates a squaring
of that so that the negative values
don't come into play all right then for
training purpose you need to use an
optimizer so what is optimizer in our
case it is a gradient descent optimizer
and we need to specify the learning rate
so you give this learning rate as in
this case we are giving as 0.001
remember what we are doing here we are
just creating a node none of these are
being executed as of now we are just
creating the graph consisting of nodes
so let me go back here what i have done
is m is created as a node b is created
as a node and similarly here optimizer
is created as a node which i will show
you little later and then when we say
train that is again another node it will
call this optimizer function and so on
right so this is not directly running
but we are just creating the graph and
then this is where we will actually run
that graph and that is where the code
will actually get executed now before
that one important thing to be
remembered in tensorflow whenever you
create variables you need to create a
node for initializing the variables
which will be executed in this session
okay whatever you can call anything here
that this is just a name but typically
it would be called init and we say tf
dot global underscore variables
underscore initializer so all the
variables that you would have created
anywhere they get initialized and it is
very important and it is only for
variables let's say in your code you
only have constants and placeholders
then this line of code is not required
but if the moment you have variables you
have to include this line basically what
are you doing here you're creating a
node or an operation you're not
executing anything you need to create an
operation and then execute the operation
within your session here okay so this is
something you need to remember so you
need to initialize the variables so this
is like a you can write once and keep
copying and pasting that's it right
because you have this anytime you have
variables now all programs may not have
variables so there may be some in your
test when you are doing some initial
development you may only do with
constants and placeholders then you will
not need it but anytime you have
variables you need to do okay all right
good so then the next step is to create
a session how do you create a session
this is kind of very in a way unique to
tensorflow you use what is known as a
width block so we say with tf.session as
says right so in other words you're say
it is somewhat saying like says is equal
to tf.session you remember there are a
couple of constructs for creating
session like in the previous example we
saw let me go back here so here we just
directly said says is equal to
tf.session this is one way of creating a
session but here what we need to
remember is at some point once you're
finished with all the code you need to
close the session okay so whereas if
you're using something like this with
block you don't have to close the
session because the moment the width
block gets completed right the session
will automatically get closed so that is
the difference and the advantages and
disadvantages of using a width block or
not a bit block okay so here what we are
saying is with tf.session assess that
means it is indirectly we are saying
create a session by the name scss and as
long as this width block is running keep
it active the moment it gets i exit this
with block you close the session right
so you don't have to explicitly close
the session okay anyway so to start with
for beginners just remember you just
have to create a width block and then
put the code within that with block and
you're good that's it okay all right so
first thing is to start with the initial
with block like this this is the syntax
then the first line of code will be to
initialize the variables again if only
if you have variables if you don't have
variables you don't have to write these
two lines of code okay then the next is
you need to run this training method
right so remember as i said we have
created all the nodes and pretty much
train was our last node and there are
all other nodes which are dependent or
rather the prerequisites right for train
train is my kind of the last part of the
node so that is what i will do a run on
because that is will give me the results
right this in turn will execute the rest
of the graph so the strain will go back
and it will say okay i need to do
optimizer.minimize and what is optimize
optimizer is gradient descent with a
learning rate of 0.001 and and then for
doing this gradient descent i have to
use this model which is mx plus b so i
need to calculate and keep changing the
values of m and b and feed the values of
x and y and so on so it's like a chain
reaction that happens and ultimately the
training gets over and then you have the
values of m and b remember the whole
exercise of actually training this is to
come up with the right values of m and b
initially we start with some random
values which is in this case 0.39 and
0.2 for m and b but the training process
if you have done the machine learning
module you will see that training
process basically involves changing
these values of m and b so that the
error is minimum so at the end of this
part which is the running of the
training session you will end up with
certain values of m and b now how do you
get those values of m and b again you
need to run the session and this is just
a one time and you say okay give me the
values of m and b okay so this is all by
the way this is all within the with
block so the session is still active
here you are saying run the training
method so it will run the training
method and the training method in turn
will keep changing the m and b values
based on the or the error that it is
generating the model is generating and
once the training is completed and how
does the system know the training is
completed we are specifying the epochs
again you must have done the machine
learning module so you will be familiar
with epochs epochs are nothing but how
many iterations you need to do if you
pass all the thousand observations
through the model for training that is
called one epoch and so if you take this
thousand observations and pass it
through the training model hundred times
that is hundred epoch so that is what we
are saying here we are asking epochs is
equal to hundred that means you perform
you pass this training data through our
model 100 times once under times are
over it will exit and remember every
epoch the values of m and b will keep
changing so that it is the error gets
optimized or error gets reduced so at
the end of the training session m and b
values will have something different
from what it has started off with so
those are the values that we will need
here which is basically m is the slope
and b is the intercept so that is the
end of the training process so we can
basically display those details and now
you can use this to plot your model the
line that you got the best fit line that
you got you can use the plot method to
plot that the line best fit line and you
will see here typically this is how it
would be right so it is passing kind of
in between all the data points so that
any point you take if you calculate the
error it is minimal compared to let's
say if the line was here obviously many
of them or most of them would have been
errors and the error value would have
been huge so that's how you evaluate the
results all right so this is my jupyter
notebook and whatever i shown you in the
slide about the linear regression i will
just quickly show you in the actual code
as a demo so we have seen that we what
we are trying to do is create a model
which is a linear regression model and
train it and then test it so this is the
the first section which is importing the
required
libraries and what we're doing here as
you can see is we have regular numpy and
we will be using that for doing some
generation of data and so on then we
have matplotlib to plot the results and
then of course we are importing the
tensorflow which is what we are going to
use for creating this linear regression
model so as a first step we will create
some artificial data which is basically
some kind of a dummy data and we are
just using numpy to do that and random
number generator and linspace to create
some data so this is how our x
underscore data looks which is our
independent data and the dependent data
is y underscore label which is the label
data in other words we can also call it
as label data and
we have created that and this is how our
data looks if we plot it x and y if we
plot it just a quick note this
randomness i've also mentioned in the
slides this random form is just added so
that the data doesn't look like it is
artificial right so right now if you see
here now it looks pretty much like some
natural data okay so what do we do now
next step is to first create some
variables which are basically for our y
is equal to mx plus b equation m and b
are the variables now there are two ways
of doing it you could have created
variables with some zero or something
both of them being zero because you need
to start with some random value in our
case what we are doing is we are
actually generating couple of random
values random numbers using the numpy
random function and we are assigning
these two variables right so we created
one value is 0.25 and another is 0.3 and
since this is random i can change this
but i will not change let's assume that
this is 39.39 and
i can actually no let us let us just
change it so you are not confused
because every time you generate a random
number it can be any value so it is 0.30
and 0.256
all right so i will now assign these two
i am creating these as tensorflow
variables i i hope you remember that in
the slide i have shown you these are the
two variables then we need to create
what is known as the cost function and
cost function is nothing but the
difference between the generated value
or the predicted value or the value
created by the model and the actual
value so that is the error that is the
difference between that and we to avoid
negative value we do a square of that so
that's what we have shown in the slides
as well then we have to define an
optimizer in our case we will go for a
gradient descent optimizer and with the
learning rate of 0.001 all right so
remember all this what we are doing is
we are creating a graph this is not yet
executed in tensorflow we are executing
in python of course but from a
tensorflow perspective it is not yet
executed only in session it will get
executed right now we are creating a
graph so we created the graph for the
training for optimizer for the
initialize operation we have create we
are creating an operation or a node okay
now that's all it's all done now we
created all the nodes we created the
graph now we have to execute the graph
so this is how we execute the graph we
create a session using tf.session and
then we specify how many iterations or
epochs which is 100 and then we run this
we run the train node you remember the
node for train we created which in turn
will go back and assign all the
variables and all that stuff okay so
once the training is done it runs for
100 epochs then we have certain values
of m and b right that's the whole
process of training you start off with
some random values of m and b and the
training will actually change those
values and come up with a particular
value of m and b such that the error is
minimum so we are done with that and now
we can check the values of k i think we
did not run this sorry so we have to run
this so this is run now so the training
is done so now we will have a value in
final underscore slope which is equal to
0.87 and then in the intercept as well
0.83 okay so we got m and b that we
wanted now we want to evaluate the
result so we want to see using our test
data whether this is doing how this is
doing so we just generate some test data
as well and this is our test data looks
and if we draw the plot of our model
this is how it looks so pretty much
expected the line is lies in between all
the data points and this is the best fit
line such that the error is minimum all
right so let's go back to the
presentation now let's talk a little bit
about recurrent neural networks so
neural networks are of different types
we have cnn we have rnn and so on now
rnn is one type of neural network rnn
stands for recurrent neural network the
networks like cnn and a n are feed
forward network which means that the
information pretty much only goes from
left to right or from front to back
whichever way you call it whereas in
case of recurrent neural network there
will be some information traveling
backwards as well so that is why it is
known as recurrent neural network and
each of these types have a specific
application so for example convolutional
neural networks or cnn are very good for
doing image processing and
object detection using for video and
images whereas recurrent neural networks
are pretty good for doing nlp or speech
recognition and so on okay so for the
next few minutes we will kind of focus
on recurrent neural networks and we will
see an example of how we can use rnn to
do a time series analysis so in a
typical neural network this is how it
looks right so where you have a neuron
and then the inputs are coming to the
neuron and then you have an output which
goes to other neurons in the other
layers in case of recurrent neural
network what happens is you have the
inputs let's say at a given point in
time but then a part of the previous
output also gets fed in along with the
inputs for the given time now this can
be a little confusing so let's see if we
can take a little expanded view of this
so this is another view of one single
neuron which is what is known as in an
unfolded manner okay so if we are
getting inputs or data over a period of
time then this is how the neuron will
look remember these are not three
neurons this is one neuron and it is
what is known as it is shown in a
unfolded way okay we are on we have
unfolded this single neuron over a
period of time so at a given time let's
say t minus 1 an input of x t minus 1 is
fed to the neuron and it gets a output
of y t minus 1 then the next instant
which is x t at a time t right there is
an input of x t and then there is an
output of yt so this is a single neuron
but is displayed in an unfolded way so
this is like expanding it over a period
of time so let's start with this part
here this particular neuron gets an
input at an instant t minus 1 let's say
time is equal to t minus 1 it gets an
input of x t minus 1 and it gives an
output of y t minus then when we go to
the instant t here it gets an input of x
t and it also additionally gets an input
from this previous time frame t minus 1.
so this y t minus 1 gets fed here and
that results in yt all right then when
we go to the time t plus 1 there is an
input of x t minus 1 at that given time
plus the input from the previous time
frame which is a time frame of t that
also gets fed in here and then we get an
output of y t plus 1 okay so let me
explain once again this is a single
neuron so these are not three different
neurons a single neuron seen over a
period of time from t minus one to t
plus one and unlike a regular feed
forward neuron which only gets x in this
case the input is x and also another
input which is coming from the previous
time frame and that is what this loop is
in this on the left hand side diagram
this loop is indicating that okay so on
the right hand side it is represented in
an unfolded way okay so the input if we
take a time frame t for example is not
only x t which is the input which is the
normal input at the time frame t but it
is also getting an input from the
previous time frame which is this yt
minus 1 is also being fed as an input
that is the key differentiator here okay
similarly at the instant t plus 1 it is
getting a normal input of x t plus 1
plus this y t is actually being fed here
and then the output comes as yt plus one
okay so this is the construct of a
recurrent neural network now recurrent
neural networks again can be of
different subtypes it can be one to one
one too many many to one and many too
many depending on what kind of
application we want to use one of the
examples is like the stock price so
you're feeding so there is only one
input only thing is it is spread over a
period of time so you're feeding the
stock price input that is what comes
here as an input and you get an output
which is again the stock price which is
probably predicted over the next uh two
days or three days or ten days or
whatever so the number of outputs and
inputs is the same there is only one
input there is only one output only
thing is it is spread over a time so
variables are not many then you have one
too many so there is one input but you
are expecting multiple outputs what is
an example of this let's say you want to
caption an image so how do you want to
do that what is the input that will go
here is just an image which is one input
but what is output you are looking for
you are looking for a phrase maybe right
not just a word but a phrase so it's
like cat is sitting on a map right so
the images there is only one image which
consists of the cat sitting on a mat but
the output are like maybe three or four
words which is saying the cat is sitting
on a mat so this is one too many right
then you can have many to one examples
of this are like you're feeding some
text and you want to know the output
whether the text is what kind of
sentiment is expressed by the text it
could be positive it could be negative
so that's the output you're looking for
so you feed a large number of words
maybe the text may consist of words or
lines or whatever so that is what is the
multiple inputs but the output all it
says is the sentiment is positive so it
is just one output or the sentiment is
negative just one output right so this
is many to one then we have many too
many so what is an example of this let's
say you want to do some translation so
how do you do a translation you feed in
a sentence maybe in a particular
language english and then you want
another a sentence actually in another
language so that is like there are
multiple inputs one sentence can consist
of multiple words and the output also is
a sentence consisting of multiple words
all right so how do we implement rnn
this is an example of implementing an
rnn for a particular use case so in our
particular example we have the data
about milk production over a few months
and using rnn we want to predict because
this is time series analysis so rnn is
good to do time series analysis so using
rnn we want to predict what will be the
milk production in the future so let us
see how we can do that i will first take
you through quickly through the slides
and then i will actually run this in in
a jupiter notebook the code i will run
it in the jupyter notebook so this is
how it looks the code looks so while
this is tensorflow you still
use the standard python libraries like
numpy and pandas and even matplotlib to
do some initial processing getting the
data processing it cleaning it whatever
all that can be still done in within the
same program so that's what we're doing
here we're importing some libraries like
numpy and pandas and then we read the
data file and if we plot the data we see
here it is the data for for the years
1962 to 75 and we can see that there is
a certain trend right so this is how a
typical time series data would look
again some of you if you're not familiar
with time series and time series
analysis and so on i would recommend you
to go through some videos around that
which will make it easy to understand
this so this is how typical time series
data would look in this case it is
nothing but there is only one variable
which is milk production and it is
spread across several years so this is
going from 1962 to 75 and that value has
been plotted so if you see there is a
certain kind of a trend here which is
basically going upwards and there will
be some seasonality so time series data
has these three components right so it
will have a trend it will have a
seasonality it will have seasonality and
then it will have some randomness so
that's what this graph is showing and
now if we want to perform analysis on
this time series analysis on this first
thing we need to do is split the data
into train and test and in this case we
will just use a straightforward method
which is uh taking the data for the
first 13 years so the idea here is we
need to train our model right this is
time series data so what and we want to
predict for the future so the way we
need to use this is we have to take the
data for a certain period of time and
train our model and then we use a part
of the known data so that we can then
ask our model to predict for that
duration and compare it with the known
information so what do we mean by that
so here if you see this data i will show
you in the notebook as well jupyter
notebook as well this has 13 years of
data so what we are doing is we are
taking the first 12 years and using that
as our training set right so 12 years we
are doing and this has about i think 14
years of data so we are taking 13 years
of data for training purpose and then we
are using the last one year remaining
one year of data for testing purpose
because here what we can do is this one
year data we know the values right
because if we want to compare the
accuracy or anything like that we need
to know the value so in this case we
know the values of this one particular
year so we will use that but at the same
time we train the model for 13 years of
data and for the 14th year we will ask
our model to predict and then compare it
with this known value so that we know
how accurate our model is i hope that
makes sense okay so that's what we are
doing here 156 is nothing but 12 into 13
on a monthly basis we get the data the
next step is to scale the data this is
all regular data manipulation data
munching activity and then you split it
you are basically assigning the train
and test data to the to the scaled
variables and then you need to read the
data in batches so
it is very important as i mentioned
earlier also that instead of reading the
entire data in one shot you feed the
data in batches so in order to do that
we are writing a a function for that
that's all we are doing here so that is
still here what we have done is regular
python programming there is no
tensorflow as of now here okay so so far
what we have done is preparation data
preparation data munching now what we
are doing is actually training our model
so this is where tensorflow now comes
into picture so we are importing first
step is to import the tensorflow library
so this is how you do it import
tensorflow sdf and then you can define
some variables or constants whichever
way now here of course there are a
couple of ways of doing it you can
create them as tensorflow nodes but that
is a little bit of an overhead we will
just use the regular python
variables are constant so here i am
creating regular python variables and i
am saying number of inputs is one so
instead of hard coding i am just storing
them as variables so this is number of
inputs is one number of time steps is 12
number of neurons is 100 and so on right
and then learning rate is 0.03 and
number of iterations we are saying is
4000 then we create placeholders now we
will be storing the independent
variables in x and the dependent
variables in y and this we will read
from an external file remember i told
you placeholders are used for getting
data from outside and then feeding it to
our model so that's the reason we have
two placeholders one for reading the x
values and another for reading the y
values in this step we are only just
creating the nodes right so this is just
creating the graph and similarly we are
mentioning what is the loss function and
what is optimizer and how to run the
optimizer and once that is done you are
initializing the variables and then
you're creating a saver variable or a
saver instance so saver is basically
nothing but in machine learning you can
train your model and you can save it for
later use so that's where the saving
comes into play we will see how to use
that as well and then the last step is
to create your session and run this
graph right so
we are initializing the variables
remember this we run init so which is
nothing but this one so we are
initializing the variables whatever are
there instead of hard coding remember in
earlier case we were hardcoding how many
iterations so here we are saying for the
given number of iterations which are
stored in this maybe how many iterations
we said is what is the value of
iterations this is training iterations
is 4000 so we specify that based on the
number of training iterations next batch
will basically fetch the data and then
we run the session we are basically
saying train is the node which we will
run in the session and this will
basically train our model and this is
more for printing every hundred times
you print it that's all this there's
nothing more to it so for example the
output would look somewhat like this
this is for 0 this 400 next for 200 and
so okay and then you save the model you
remember saver we created so you save
the model for later use so this is our
test data remember we are doing this on
training data right so once the training
data training is done we then try to
create the inference on the test data so
that we can compare how accurate this is
right so this is how the test set would
look and then we will basically restore
this model okay because in the previous
slide we created the model and we stored
it so now we have to restore the model
and then run our test data against it
and see what are the values that are
predicted what are the y values and then
compare with x to see the accuracy so
train seed is what we are seeing here so
that is what will have the predicted
values and
these predicted values what we want to
do is we want to create an additional
column because remember we need to
compare because we want to find out the
accuracy of this model so we need to
compare the predicted values with the
actual value so what we are doing here
is adding another column called
generator and
assign a value to that all right so this
is the result of the prediction and then
if we need to reshape because we have to
show this in the form of monthly results
so that's what we're doing here and
once we generate the results and then
display it we can actually see it
month-wise here and
the actual and the generated values okay
so we create a data frame which is a
combination of the actual values and the
predicted values from the test set and
then we can plot to see how the trend is
as you can see pretty much the actual
value is in blue color and generated or
predicted value the curve is in yellow
color the trend is maintained so it will
probably it's not a hundred percent
accurate but the trend is maintained all
right so let's do one thing let's go
into the jupiter notebook and take a
look at how this works in tensorflow
environment actually the code i will
walk you through the code this is my
jupiter notebook and
the data is taken from this particular
link in case you're interested you can
download it from there and this is the
data for the years
1962-75 the first thing we do is import
these libraries because before we start
with the actual tensorflow activity we
need to prepare the data and so on so
for that you can use your regular python
libraries which are like numpy pandas
and so on so that's what we're doing
here and then we read the data using
pandas into a data frame so this is a
data frame milk is a data frame and we
will do some quick exploratory analysis
just to see how our data is looking
initials five records that we'll get one
two three four five that is ahead so it
goes from 1960 to january to 1962 may
once we read change or basically we need
to split this into month specifically
separately so that's what we are doing
here date to time so we kind of do a
little bit of reindexing and then if we
plot this this is how the data look as
you can see there is a clear upward
trend and
there is some seasonality and so on but
anyway we will not break that up into
those components we will just use rnn to
predict and test okay so the next thing
is to check some if we can do run like
info it will tell us what is the
information about this data set so let
us just run that okay that is just
telling us how many total columns and
what is the size of the file and so on
and so forth again in case you're
interested in doing some exploratory
analysis so what we'll do next is we
will take the 13 years of data for our
training data set so what are we going
to do now let me step back so what have
we seen here we have seen that there are
168 records so which is nothing but 14
years of data we now have to split this
into our training and test data set so
how do we do that i think in case of
time series we cannot do it like 80 20
like we do in normal splitting in normal
machine learning process here it is time
series data so what we are going to do
is we will take out of this 14 years we
will take the first 13 years of data and
we will use that for training and then
we will test it with the last which is
the 14th year data we will use it for
testing okay so that's what we are going
to do here so let's uh split that so
training set will consist of my 156
records which is nothing but 12 13 into
12 right my 13 years of data i'm taking
for training and then my test set will
consist of the bottom 12 observations
which is last one year of data which is
the 14th year okay so that's now done
training and test splitting is done the
next step is to do some normalizing
which is basically we'll use our scaling
rather we will use min max scalar and we
will just scale the data and now we do
it for both test as well as train now we
are ready to create our rnn model but
before that one quick thing in order to
fetch the data we have to create a
function so that's what we are doing
here we create a function called next
batch and
how you want to fetch the steps they are
all defined as our constants if you
remember and that's what this function
is all about so we define that function
we will be calling that in our training
method all right so from here onwards up
to there we are done with the
preparation of the data and whatever
functions or whatever are required from
here onwards is where the tensorflow
part starts so the first thing we do is
import the tensorflow library typically
this is a very standard way of importing
the library we say import tensorflow as
tf now tf is nothing but a name so you
can change it to tf1 or abc or xyz
whatever so this part you can change but
by and large everybody uses this so we i
would rather recommend you also use the
same syntax so you say import tensorflow
sdf so it's very easy for others to
understand as well and then you declare
or define a bunch of constants that's
what we are doing here like for example
the number of time steps in this case it
is 12 number of neurons there are 100
number of outputs it is only one and so
on right and then the learning rate and
all that we are declaring or defining
those variables in this particular block
next is to create placeholders you
remember the placeholders are used for
feeding the data so we have x and y x is
for the input which is the independent
variable and y is the output which is
the dependent variable and in our case
these are not different characteristics
or features but it is the same one
feature or one variable but it is over a
period of time so that's the only
difference so that's what we are doing
here and now we need to create our
network right the neural network so in
our case we said we will create a rnn
layer now there are different ways or
different formats of rnn which is
probably not in scope of this module so
for now we will just assume we are
creating one rnn layer and one type of
rnn is gru cell so we will use gru cell
and we use this apis for creating our
layer so each cell will be with an
output projection wrapper there is a
need for doing that and again the
details of this we will probably do in
another video where we talk in detail
about rnn so for now we are creating a
gre cell with the wrapper and the syntax
for creating the gru cell is uh like
this the number of units which we we
said there should be 100 neurons what
will be the activation function in this
case it is relu and then number of
outputs in our case it is only one okay
so we create the cell here okay then we
got the gru cell and then we say what is
our output which is nothing but we get
the outputs and the states and their
states and which is uh the way we get
that is tf.nnn
dot dynamic underscore rnn so if we call
this and we pass the cell and the data
which is basically in placeholder again
remember all we are doing here is we are
creating just the nodes for the graph so
nothing is actually getting executed
from a tensorflow perspective okay all
right so once that is done now we need
to pass this calculate the outputs and
the states using the dynamic underscore
rna method and we pass the cell as a
parameter and then the x values as a
parameter and if we
run that we will have the outputs and
the states and this is where we actually
run the training method
so
or create not really run the training
method but we create the nodes for the
training and optimizer then we have the
initialization of the variables and we
save this model we create a saver object
just to save the model because we will
then restore it and run it to do our
predictions so this is what we will do
here so that is another node and this is
where we actually create a session and
run the training okay so let's go ahead
and do that that will take a little
while because we said 4000 iterations so
we will allow it to finish we will
probably come back once the training is
completed all right so the training is
done now let's go and
run this on the test data so let's just
quickly take a look at the test data set
so this is our one year data for the
year of 1975 so if we see this is from
january february and so on and we will
pass this to our model so what are we
doing here we are restoring the model
here for example right this is the path
that we have given when we were saving
the model let's go back once and show
you let me show you where we did the
saving of the model yes so we save the
model here so that again we will restore
that and we will use that to run it on
our test data and see how well it
predicts so let's go ahead and run this
and this is just 12 records so this will
not take time remember i told you
training is what takes a lot of time the
regular inference this is called
inference doesn't take much time right
so it just depends on how much data
there were only 12 records here so it
was very quick but in training what we
do we pass this multiple times there are
iterations 4 000 iterations we did for
example so that takes longer and in
general in machine learning deep
learning training is what takes the
maximum amount of time all right so
let's go ahead and see the results we
will in order to plot it we will have to
kind of adjust the format of the results
otherwise we will not be able to see it
in a proper way and then we will so this
is our so what we have done is we
created a data frame which consists of
the predicted value and
and the actual value so this is the data
frame so this is the actual value this
is 8 34 782 and so on this is what our
model has predicted so it may not be so
easy to see in a table format so let's
go ahead and plot it so that we can
compare these two so when we plot it you
will see that the trend is more or less
maintained right so we go from the blue
color is the actual values and the
yellow color or the orange color
whatever is it is the one which is
generated by our model so it pretty much
is following the actual trend so not bad
for such a quick iteration and uh
training so that is basically it hello
and welcome to the tensorflow object
detection api tutorial in this video i
will walk you through the tensorflow
code to perform object detection in a
video so let's get started this part is
basically you're importing all the
libraries we need a lot of these
libraries for example numpy
we need image i o date time and bill and
so on and so forth and of course
matplotlib so we import all these
libraries and then there are a bunch of
variables which have some parts for the
files and folders so this is regular
stuff let's keep moving then we import
the matplotlib and make it inline and
a few more imports all right and then
these are some warnings we can just
ignore them so if i run this code once
again it will go away right and then
here onwards we do the model preparation
what we are going to do is we are going
to use an existing neural network model
so we are not going to chain a new one
because that really will take a long
time and it needs a lot of computation
resources and so on and it is really not
required there are already models that
have been trained and in this case it is
the ssd with mobile net that's the model
that we are going to use and this model
is trained to detect objects and it is
readily available as open source so we
can actually use this and if you want to
use other models there are a few more
models available so you can click on
this
link here and
let me just take you there there are few
more models but we have chosen this
particular one because this is faster it
may not be very accurate but that is one
of the faster models but on this link
you will see a lot of other models that
are readily available these are trained
models some of them would take a little
longer but they may be more accurate and
so on so you can probably play around
with these other models okay so we will
be using that model so this piece of
code this line is basically importing
that model and this is also known as
frozen model the term we use is frozen
model so we import download and import
that and then we will actually use that
model in our code all right so these two
cells
we have downloaded and import the model
and then once it is available locally we
will then load this into our program all
right so
we are loading this into memory and
you need to perform a couple of
additional steps which is basically we
need to map the numbers to
text as you may be aware when we
actually build the model and when we run
predictions the model will not give a
text the output of the model is usually
a number so we need to map that to a
text so for example if the network
predicts that the output is 5 we know
that 5 means it is an airplane things
like that so this mapping is done in
this next cell all right so let's keep
moving and then we have a helper code
which will basically load the data or
load the images and transform into numpy
arrays this is also used in doing object
detection in images so we are actually
going to reuse because video is nothing
but it consists of frames which in turn
are images so we are going to pretty
much use reuse the same code which we
used for doing object detection in
images so this is where the actual
detection starts so here this is the
path for where the images are stored so
this is here once again we are reusing
the code which we wrote for detecting
objects in an image so this is the path
where the images were stored and this is
the extension and this was done for
about two or three images so we will
continue to use this and
we go down i'll skip this section so
this is the cell where we are actually
loading the video and converting it into
frames and then using frame by frame we
are detecting the objects in the image
so in this code what we are doing
basically is there are a few lines of
code what they do is basically once they
find an object a box will be drawn
around those
each of those objects and the input file
the name of the input video file is
traffic it is the extension is mp4 and
we have this video reader it's a
excellent object which is basically part
of this class called image i o so we can
read and write videos using that and the
video that we are going to use is
traffic.mp4 you can use any mp4 file but
in our case i picked up video which has
like car so let me just show you so this
is in this object detection folder i
have this mp4 file i'll just quickly
play this video it's a little slow yeah
okay so here we go this is the video
it's a short one relatively small video
so that for this particular demo and
what it will do is once we run our code
it will detect each of these cars and it
will annotate them as cars so in this
particular video we only have cars we
can later on see with another video i
think i have cat here so we can also try
with that but let's first check with
this traffic video so let me go back so
we will be reading this frame by frame
and
you know actually we will be
reading the video file but then we will
be analyzing it frame by frame and we
will be reading them at 10 frames per
second that is the rate we are
mentioning here and analyzing it and
then annotating and then writing it back
so you will see that we will have a
video file named something like this
traffic underscore annotated and
we will see the annotated video so let's
go back and run through this piece of
code and then we will come back and see
the annotated video this might take a
little while so i will pause the video
after
running this particular cell and then
come back to show you the results all
right so let's go ahead and run it so it
is running now and it is also important
that at the end you close the video
writer so that it is similar to a file
pointer when you open a file you should
also make sure you close it so that it
doesn't hog the resources so it's very
similar at the end of it the last piece
or last line of code should be video
underscore writer dot close all right so
i'll pause and then i'll come back okay
so i will see you in a little bit all
right so now as you can see here the
processing is done the hourglass has
disappeared that means the video has
been processed so let's go back and
check the annotated video go back to my
file manager so this was the original
traffic.mp4 and now you have here
traffic underscore annotated mp4 so
let's go and run this and see how it
looks
you see here just got each of these cars
are getting detected let me pause and
show you so we pause here it says car 70
let us allow it to go a little further
it detects something on top what is that
truck okay so i think because of the
board on top it somehow thinks there is
a truck let's play it some more and see
if it detects anything else so this is
again a car looks like so let us yeah so
this is a car and
it has confidence level of 69 percent
okay this is again a car all right so
basically till the end it goes and
detects each and every car that is
passing by now we can quickly repeat
this process for another video let me
just show you the other video which is a
cat again there is uh this cat is not
really moving or anything but it is just
standing there staring and moving a
little slowly and our application will
our network will detect that this is a
cat and
even when the cat moves a little bit in
the other direction it will continue to
detect and show that it is a cat okay so
yeah so this is how the original video
is let's go ahead and change our code to
analyze this one and see if it detects
our network detects this cat close this
here we go and go back to my code all we
need to do is change this traffic to
cat the extension it will automatically
pick up because it is given here and
then it will run through so very quickly
once again what it is doing is this
video reader video underscore reader has
a neat little feature or interface
whereby you can say for frame in video
underscore reader so it will basically
provide frame by frame so you're in a
loop frame by frame and then you take
that each frame that is given to you you
take it and analyze it as if it is an
image individual image so that's the way
it works so it is very easy to handle
this all right so now let's once again
run just this cell the rest of the stuff
remains the same so i will run this cell
again it will take a little while so the
hourglass has come back i will pause and
then come back in a little while all
right so the processing is done let's go
and check the annotated video go here so
we have get annotated dot mp4 let's play
this all right so you can see here just
detecting the cat and in the beginning
you also saw it detected something else
here there looks like it detected one
more object so let's just go back and
see what it has detected here
let's see yes
so
what is it trying to show here it's too
small not able to see but
it is trying to detect something i think
it is saying it is a car i don't know
all right okay so in this video there's
only pretty much only one object which
is the cat and
let's wait for some time and see if it
continues to detect it when the cat
turns around and moves as well just
in a little bit that's going to happen
and we will see there we go and
in spite of turning the other way i
think our network is able to detect that
it is a cat so let me freeze and then
show here it is actually still continues
to detect it as a cat all right so
that's pretty much it i think that's the
only object that it detects in this
particular video okay so close this so
that's pretty much it this is a list of
libraries that are required and they
have been shown in the code as well the
exact purpose of each of this library
why it is required is out of the scope
of this tutorial but we will see in the
code as we walk through some of these
libraries how and why they are used the
cocoa data set coco stands for common
objects in context so this data set
consists of 300 000 images of
90 most commonly found objects like
chairs and tables and so on and so forth
so
this model has been trained or in fact a
set of models have been trained on this
data set and this is pretty good to
detect the most common objects in the
images and videos so with that let's get
into the code all right so the first
part is to import all these libraries
and this we have shown you in the slides
as well again a bunch part of this will
be for doing some helper functions and
maybe for visualizing the images and so
on and so forth so that's the reason
they are required as i said the exact
details of each and every library
probably is out of scope but these are
needed so as a first step maybe you just
go ahead and include these libraries and
run the code and maybe a later point we
can discuss what each of these libraries
does now this will work with tensorflow
version higher than 1.4 so if you are
having tensorflow version below 1.4 you
may have to upgrade to a higher version
so let me go ahead and execute the cell
and
we also need this line of code to make
sure that once we
run this object detection the labeled
images are displayed within this
notebook and many of you by now must be
familiar with this and we will import a
few utility libraries and you will see
that we will be using some of these
for visualization purpose so once the
objects are detected we need to display
the information what that object is and
then what percentage of confidence the
model has so all these details that's
the utility functions that stored here
and then the next part is to prepare the
model as i mentioned we will be using an
existing trained model
the tensorflow team has actually
provided these models the one that we
will be using is ssd with the mobile net
but you can actually use any one of the
ones that are listed in this url let me
just quickly take you through this url
these are a bunch of models trained
models that are readily available for
anybody to use it is open source and let
me scroll down the only thing is that if
there are some of them with the accuracy
is much higher but they take longer and
there are some where the accuracy is not
so high and they are much faster so they
are faster but the accuracy may not be
that very high so you can play around
with some of these and we in this
particular exercise or in this
particular tutorial we are using this
ssd model which is ssd mobile at
question one so that's the model that
we'll be using so in this cell we are
primarily creating a bunch of variables
with the various for example the name of
the model the path and so on and so
forth so that we will be using these
names in the next step which is to
download this model and install it
locally these are also referred to as a
frozen model so once they are trained
and then you kind of extract or you
freeze the model so that's the reason
they are called frozen model so that
others can just use this without any
further training so this is where we
download and extract our model locally
so this will take a little while let me
see if i can wait or maybe pause the
video and come back once it is done
might take a little while let's see if
it
completes i have a pretty high speed
network but even then it takes some time
so that's good but this part is over now
let us see this part and yes both are
done so once that is done we need to
load some label mapping our basically
what this will do is your model as you
may be aware by now if you do some
classification the model will actually
not give any output
text it will give some numbers so if
there are five classes it will say okay
this belongs to modern class one or two
or three or five and so on the numbers
now each of these will obviously the
numbers will not make any sense to the
outside world so we need to do some
small mapping so in this case let's say
one may be a chair two maybe a table
three maybe a balloon and so on so that
kind of number to text mapping we need
to do and that is what is being done in
this particular cell and then we have a
helper code which will load the image
and convert it into a numpy array so
that the number array is what gets
processed and used by the model to do
the detection part of it so that is what
this
method is all about so we will be the
later on we will be calling that
function and
next is preparation for detection so
here we are basically telling where the
images are stored and how many images or
what is the naming convention or format
of the images now if you want you can
modify this code for example currently i
have test underscore images as my folder
so let me go and show this to you so
this is under my object detection folder
i have another subfolder where i am
storing my images which is text
underscore images now you can rename
this folder and give some other name and
then in your code you can probably give
that particular name for the subfolder
similarly the format of these files what
is the name and format of this files
here it is in a very simple format which
is the names of the files are like beach
one beach two b3 and so on so i have
taken beach as the theme so i have
images which are related to beaches so
this is beach one beach two and then
beach three a few others but we will use
these three for our demo and so that's
what i'm saying here the name of the
images will be beach something dot jpeg
which is uh jpeg format and in this
curly braces basically we will will be
filled with either
one two or three based on in this
particular for loop okay so that is what
this is doing all right so the next step
is to run inference on these images in a
loop and what we are basically doing
here is
getting these images one by one and then
running through the model to find out
what are the objects that can be
detected and then against each of the
object a box will be drawn and it will
be labeled with the name and the
percentage of accuracy or confidence
that the model detects these objects
okay so that is
the function here and so let me just run
that piece of code and here is basically
where we are calling this function so we
are loading this images and then we are
calling this function for each image and
then we are displaying this using the
matplotlib library so let's run this it
will take one image at a time and then
detect the images now the beauty is that
the same format of the code can be used
for doing object detection in a video so
we have another video for doing object
detection
in a video so most of the code out there
will be reused from here and the only
thing is that instead of reading the
images from the local storage
we read the frames from the video and
there is a neat little video reader that
is available and it will be shown in the
other video and frame by frame we read
the video and then pass on to this
function and it will act as if each of
these frames is an image and then it
will do the same object detection on the
entire video so that's in a separate
video just look out for that and
actually the information about that is
provided in the cards the eye symbol so
that's the the video object detection in
video that's the separate uh tutorial
all right so now that we have all the
pieces together this the last cell is
where the whole action takes place so
let's run this and see how it looks so
it will take probably a little while and
there are about three images let's see
what it detects there we go so good so
the first one it has detected a person
and that too with 97 accuracy which is i
think pretty good okay and then the next
image it detects umbrella and chair
there are a few other objects but it's
not able to detect it has detected
umbrella with 63 percent accuracy or
confidence rather and the chair with 58
percent again not bad
then let's see the next image so here
these are actually balloons hot air
balloons but the model thinks it is a
kite which is uh probably not that bad
it sees there is something in the sky
and therefore probably it thinks it is a
kite and it detects that with 65 percent
confidence okay so that was pretty much
all i wanted to show you in this
particular tutorial about object
detection in images the most popular
deep learning library in the world it
has really once they open sourced it it
was just amazing how much it's spread in
use and how many tools are linked into
tensorflow tensors are vectors or
matrices of n dimensions and you can see
here we have dimension five we have a
dimension four by five or five by four
as the case is five rows by four columns
here's one there's three by three by
three and so this is kind of nice
because when you're processing pictures
there's certain things you want to do
where you want the pixels to be next to
each other that's very important same
thing with your processing say a movie
you might want a three by three grid
coming in where you have the layers of
the frames coming in to be processed so
you can see how having different
dimensions is really helpful in
analyzing certain data structures and
this is what's so great about tensors is
you can of course flatten them out like
we did earlier or you can process them
based on their location in tensorflow
all computations performed involve
tensors so everything going through is
always looked at as tensors as a matrix
or matrixes of n dimension tensorflow
architecture is as follows
pre-processing data build a model train
and estimate the model and what we'll do
is we'll go ahead and dig into use case
imitation with tensorflow to do that i'm
actually going to go into
in this case of you using the anaconda
navigator and you can use either jupiter
lab or jupiter notebook most people are
very familiar with jupiter notebook it's
very commonly web-based the jupiter lab
is the next version of jupyter notebook
and it just lets you have multiple tabs
open when you're working on it and if
you're using anaconda you'll go under
environments and you'll want to make
sure that you have your tensorflow
installed and you can simply we'll do
this i have it installed uh but you
could do all the do all you can do is
search under all for tensor and you can
see all the different tensors it's
actually installed in here version
1.13.1
if it wasn't you could check the box and
then run the install on there and it'd
bring it right in but we'll go and start
up our jupiter lab which is going to
open up in this case i use google chrome
and in our jupyter lab or jupiter
notebook if you're in the notebook you
only have one tab and you won't have the
added options like there's a folder and
different things you can do in the lab
that you can't do in the notebook but
everything we're going to do you can
easily do in the notebook and you'll
start up a new project deep learning is
what i'm going to call this and if
you're not familiar you can definitely
we have some tutorials out on the use of
jupiter notebook and how to run it and
set it up and things like that the most
basic is we put our code in here it has
a nice display a nice interface
especially for data science i can
display all kinds of things on this page
and then you can just run this page
right here there's no code in it so it's
not going to show any thing until i put
some code in there and of course you can
cut your cells and things like that so
the first thing we want to do is we want
to import our tools now if you haven't
remember you gotta install tensorflow
and we'll also use pandas pandas is a
nice database setup and that again is
underneath your environment and you can
see here your whatever you're working on
i simply learned setup where i've
installed tensorflow and pandas in here
and i'll simply go up here and run this
not going to see anything so we've just
imported those into our notebook that
we're working on so those are now
available to us and it helps to have
some data to work with and we have here
going to create a path and a test path
and
we'll go ahead and let's just highlight
this whole path and you can always post
a note either down below in the youtube
video or you can post a note on
simplylearn.com and ask for this path if
you're not quite picking it up but it is
over here at the uci edu on their setup
and it's in their archive so it's
archive.ics.uci.edu
forward slash ml for machine learning
slash machine dash learning dash
databases slash adult that's quite a
mouthful and in this case we have adult
data and adult test well let's go and
just take a look at that let me just
paste that right in there to our browser
window and here's our adult data and if
i click on there it's going to come down
as a download i'm going to go ahead and
open it as a text in my notepad um and
the guys in the back were kind enough to
look up to find out what the actual
columns were in this uh coming across so
let me do and take that to pull that
information it doesn't matter whether i
put it before or below because these are
just variables uh but we can see here
that we have age work class final wgt
i'm guessing that's final we'll look
that up in just a second see what that
matches in fact let's pull that up and
just put them next to each other so we
can kind of see we got here so we have
age we have our working class state gov
maybe final wage 77 516 education a
bachelor's education number 13 marital
never married admin clerical
relationship not in family so on and so
on so it goes all the way across here so
we've pulled out this information native
country label etc we'll go ahead and run
this and so now we've loaded all our
different
paths and this path by the way this is
the same columns on here so i don't need
to create a separate columns on the
adult test and once we've run this we've
set those variables let's go ahead and
pull that data in and to do that we'll
use pandas and we'll create a df train a
df test
each one's going to have our pd for
pandas.readcsv
they'll have our path we put in there
our path test the first one went ahead
and skip initial space true names
columns there's our columns in there
index column equals false there's no
index column on the second one if we
went back into here and we open up adult
test let me just go ahead and open that
up pad you'll see there's an actual row
up here we want to skip a 1 by 3 cross
validator with all the same data in it
so we're looking at the same data in
there and here we're going to go ahead
and bring in our data and then once you
bring it in it's always nice to see what
kind of shape your data is in and of
course when we talk about shape we're
talking about how many rows and columns
not whether it's been lifting weights we
can see here we have each one has 15
columns and that goes with our columns
right here if we counter them there's
going to be 15. and the first data set
has 32
rows where the second one has 16
281 rows and it's also good to see just
how the data came in so we'll use the
pandas
d types we'll run that and you can see
here where age came in as an integer
integer 64. working class has an object
which makes sense
and then we have our
fnlwgt the education is objects or well
this is an integer integer object so on
all the way down and if we flash back to
the data we look at the last column it's
less than or equal to 50k and if we
scroll down enough we'll see it's also
greater than or equal to 50k so we'd
like to kind of give that its own
special setup on that label so on that
feature we're going to set the label
equal to
if it's less than or equal to 50k it's
going to be 0 and if it's greater than
or equal to 50k it's going to be 1. so
it's one or the other that's always an
easy easy thing to read and then we can
take this and we go dftrain.label
equals label item for item and df train
label and this just loops through all
the labels there's a lot of ways we can
do this pandas this might be actually
kind of a slower way there's a way to do
just that setup and do the logic within
the
setup instead of doing a loop but for
this this thing will work fine we're not
dealing with a lot of data you know it's
a large data set but it's not that big
of a data set as data goes and we also
want to do it for our test data i didn't
really mention that we created two date
we're looking at two different data sets
one we're going to train the data and
then we're going to take it and run the
test data to see if it works so we have
our two different data sets and we
didn't catch it off the bat if you were
pulling up this you're going to pull up
one the this is the training set and if
we go back in here and open up the test
set let me just go back and do that
adult test one of the things that we
didn't notice that you'll want to pull
up is at the end there's a period so
we're pre-processing our data we want to
make sure that we include that period in
every line on the second set up so when
i go back to my jupiter notebook i've
got to have a label t which is less than
or equal to 50k period or greater than
equal to 50k period for one otherwise
it's doing the exact same thing we're
going to change uh the df train label
the df test label to zero or one we'll
just run that we'll go ahead and print
the df train label dot value counts and
the df test label value counts this is
always a good idea because we want to
know is there any weird stuff going on
there if there's no value stuff like
that this will turn up on that setup and
we can see here we have
zeros how many zeros how many ones and
so on on there just a quick view of the
data that we're going through and if we
go back up here go ahead and print the
train d types again and we run that you
could actually run it up there and give
you the new answer because this loaded
this information uh we now see it's an
integer and if you go back up here it
was an object so that makes life a
little easier as far as what we're doing
with this now at this point we're going
to look at the data and we can see we
have a lot of numbers and we have a lot
of categories in here uh so categories
would be united states male never
married versus seven and we can also see
that when we looked at this we have our
integers we have our objects working
class so the next thing we want to do on
there is we want to go ahead and take
that where we have integers and the
objects and we want to bring that down
here we want to create those categories
in a way that the computer can see them
and we'll start with our
continuous features like age we can see
age integer fnl wgt is an integer
capital gain is an integer educational
number there's our educational numbers
an integer and so on uh so if we're
going to have these as continuous
features where they're an integer we
also need to make a list of the
categorical features we want to work
with such as working class education
marital occupation relationship race sex
and native country and again these are
all objects so that makes sense and when
we flip back over to the data we can see
here we're actually looking at united
states if we continue down see if i can
find another one a lot of united states
on this particular one i was getting
worried there for a second that we only
had united states and it was a very
biased uh census which it probably is
for wherever it came from and of course
bachelor's associate vocational some
college uh so you can see this is more
categorical versus an actual number so
now we have our
categorical and we have our continuous
features and this is just the list of
these so let's go ahead and run that and
load that list in there so we can now
start manipulating our data with it now
we get our first line of tensor flow
code which is exciting and we're going
to create a variable continuous features
and what we're doing in here is we're
going to go into tf
feature columns so we have the feature
columns we're going to set those up
numeric columns k for k in continual
features so this is going to go in here
and says each one of these is a
continual feature we're going to feed
that into the feature column not very
exciting on the output because we're
just creating this variable here letting
it know what columns are what then we're
going to create a
relationship
setup so we have continuous features and
then we have a relationship and again
we're doing tf but in this case we use
feature column so just like this one
we're telling it feature column and now
we do categorical column with vocabulary
list so it's one of the things we can do
with tensorflow and we're going to feed
it one we have relationship and so we're
just drilling down to the relationship
column and these are the options they
had so this is going to be the
vocabulary attached to this column and
we'll go ahead and run that so we load
up our relationship and then we're going
to do one more uh way of loading uh in
this one we're going to do categorical
features and so in categorical features
we're going to do tf feature column
there's our command we've already seen
before it's going to be categorical
column with hash bucket we're going to
create buckets in this case for k and
categorical features so it's going to
create a bucket for each one of these uh
categorical features and the bucket size
is 1000. so we're looking at and we've
actually kind of repeated something
because relationship is also in the
bucket setup on there but we want to
show you three major ways of loading in
your different features one is our
features that we know where it's going
to be a number uh so our continuous
features then we can set it as a
relationship in this case we actually
created a vocabulary husband not in
family very clear vocabulary on there
and then we also are loading just
general categories into buckets you can
set different bucket settings in here we
went ahead and just went with a thousand
so pretty much everything since there's
not a huge number of categories each one
gets their own kind of bucket set up in
there and as far as the initial setup we
need to go ahead and create a model so
this is where it starts to come together
we've as far as the pre-set up we have
our tf we have an estimator we're going
to do linear classifier on the estimator
in classes equals two so we know there's
only two classes we're looking at we
have ongoing train feature columns and
then we have our different we have
categorical features plus continuous
features so this basically creates our
model what data is going in and we'll go
ahead and run this and you can see here
that it gives us a little information
that we had our tensorflow using default
config you can change a lot of defaults
you can change as far as the model
directory uh random seed saving summary
checkpoints there's all kinds of things
you can go in here and set up rewrite
options keep checkpoint mix etc at this
point the model hasn't done anything all
we've done is create the model uh so
let's just do a real quick rehash of
what we've done so far what we started
off with is we grab some data in this
case uh adult and adult test we have a
training data set and a test data set uh
we set the columns up we took a very
short brief exploration of the data in
its shape as far as what we're working
with we changed our label around a
little bit so that the label makes a
little bit more sense of 0 1 instead of
for the machine it's easier to spit out
a zero or a one we can look up here we
double check to make sure we how many
zeros and ones we have double check our
data make sure it's integer 64. nothing
weird is going on and then we look to
three different ways that we can kind of
label the data as far as the way we're
going to read it we have our continuous
features and a categorical features
here's a relationship which is one of
them we went ahead and created our model
we did not put the relationship in here
which you can do you can actually maybe
take it out of categorical and then have
its own on here instead of having
categorical features and continuous
features and so on so we've created our
setup for our model the next thing we
need to do is we need to go ahead and
create a function letting it know how to
read the data into our model how are we
going to train it and let's go ahead and
create two variables the first one is
going to be features this is just all
the features that are in there and then
the second one is going to be our label
and this is basically we're looking at
all the different information we can put
into it and then is that person based on
that information going to make less than
or greater than 50k that's what that
comes down to now the next part the
definition we're going to create has a
lot in it and we're going to feed this
definition into our model training so
there's a lot of stuff that goes on here
first we'll call it get input and
function def get input function we have
our data set number of epics equals none
in batch equals 128 shuffle equals true
so we're running this and it's going to
return a tf estimator inputs pandas
input function and in this case it's
going to be x equals our pd data frame k
data set k values for k in features y is
pd series data set label values batch
size equals n batch number of epics
equals number of epochs shuffle equals
shuffle so in here we're passing in uh
the number of epochs we're not too
worried about we're going to just go
once through the data because there's a
lot of data in there we don't need to
rerun it epics is how many times do you
cover all the data and then how many
groups of data do you pull in and batch
at a time so we're only going to look at
128 do the reverse propagation like we
talked about uh and then it'll go to the
next batch and the next batch and the
next batch and it shuffles them so
shuffle means that we're randomly
picking where they're coming from uh
like again we're only doing we're not
too worried about the number of epics
for this particular model depending on
how much data you have and depending
what you're running depends on how many
epics you need to run and there's a lot
of rules on how many epics you need to
run one of them is if you're
training data and you're testing data
because you'll check your testing data
against your training data if your
testing data starts having a better
results in your training data that means
you're no longer fitting towards the
data but you're fitting to the answer so
it's kind of these little weird things
you start to on here and tensorflow is
really cool because it actually checks a
lot of that for you but we're just going
to set number of epics equal to zero and
then we have our data set going in so
we're creating our get function how do
we get the data into training our model
and we'll go ahead and run that so now
we have our data function and now it
knows where the data is coming from so
we need to go ahead and train it and
that simply would take our model we
created way up here that's we take the
model there we've told it what columns
is going to pull in so it knows what
columns it's looking at know what the
definition was going to get the
information from so now we want to go
ahead and train it and here's our input
function equals in this case get input
function and here we tell it that our
data set is a df train number of epics
equals none which is already
automatically set up there in batch
equals 128 which is what we have up here
shuffle equals false and we're going to
do 1000 steps so we're actually going to
go through
128 batches but we're gonna do that a
thousand times and we'll go ahead and
run this and i just ran an update so
it's going to give me some warnings
because of that update and then we're
back here and it's still going to
construct pipelines use tf data module
not a big problem we let it go ahead and
run all the way through one here and it
takes it just a moment there we go
there's our thousand coming out as you
can see here here's a checkpoints for
one thousand ongoing training a thousand
and one global steps and this is just
all the reverse propagation going on
that's what we're doing here uh one of
the things we didn't cover is we do it
in small increments so it's not all done
like one error goes all the way back
you'd only do a part of that error and
each one sends back a little piece since
you slowly adjust your different weights
going all the way back and then if
you're going to train your model we want
to know how it did so we're going to do
model evaluate and our input function
equals remember our input function up
here that we created way up here we're
going to take this input function and
instead of the data set that's coming in
we put in the data set here for training
where's our training input train there
we go df underscore train
now we're going to go ahead and evaluate
and here it is a git input function test
so we're going to test the data out
number of epochs one we don't need to
rerun it more than once per batch 128
so on shuffle and steps a thousand so
we're going to go ahead and evaluate
this let's just see how good our test
data did uh how good our model was
programmed on our training data and how
it evaluates on the test and we can see
it going on down here where it's got the
evaluating graph was finalized let me
just highlight that ongoing model
checkpoint tensorflow running local init
evaluate 100 out of a thousand and so on
and once it gets to the end we get a
nice
output here we have an accuracy in this
case of 0.79
with a baseline of 0.76 so now we've
created a model uh let's go ahead and
tweak it a little bit so we have our
accuracy up here what we're going to do
is we're going to look at age and let's
just go ahead and create a new square
value for age and the reason we want to
look into the square value of age is we
know that if you really look through the
data you'll find that as a young person
the age keeps increasing as you get
close to retirement it begins to
decrease so we square the value of age
and that's very data specific when we're
looking at data you'll find that any
kind of data that has that kind of like
uptick and downtick by squaring it or
square rooting it you can get some very
different results and so we're going to
go and square our age and this is kind
of it's interesting because at this
point even at the beginning of this
we're focused on deep learning and on
tensorflow but before i would begin even
looking at any of this i would have
probably run some kind of heat map or
some kind of evaluation in r or sk learn
in python to find out the correlation
between different features to see just
how well they correlate to each other
and there certainly are some wonderful
tools for that because sometimes you can
just mark off some features and other
features you bring in but for the deep
learning we can see how we can just dump
it all in there and let it sort it out
itself and we're going to just write a
quick little function here to take the
square variable in this case we have dft
dfte this is our training and your test
variable and the variable age coming in
and we just want to go ahead and create
a new under dft and the new is going to
be the variable name whatever we put in
there which will be age so let's load
this here's our functions now loaded and
certainly we could have just done that
as a line of code but you start to get
the feeling that when you build these
functions you might use that you can now
use this function if you had a number of
different features that had this kind of
quality to them and we have our df train
new so we're going to create a new
training and a new test and it's going
to equal the square variable df train or
df test and the variable name is age and
let's just go ahead and run that and so
now we have our new our df train new and
df test new and just like we did before
let's just double check the shape of our
data and make sure it all matches and
when we look at the output here really
what's important is that each one of
these has 16 features in it we want to
make sure we're not getting something
weird on there and our training set has
561 rows in it and this one has just
over 16 000 in there and everything's
pretty much the same except that in our
continuous features new we now have the
new column we put in there so we need to
change that and we have our continuous
features new down here which we're going
to load up with our tf feature column
numerical this would all look familiar
because we just did this and so we're
going to load that up with the new being
the new value in there let's go ahead
and run that and we'll create a model
that we'll call it model one and this is
the same that we did before except now
we have our continuous features new in
here so here's our new model in this
case model one instead of model and
we're going to build that model right
there now we haven't trained it all
we've done is told it where to get the
data and how to get the data and what
features are coming in we haven't
actually told it everything on the
features coming in because we still need
to also build our full our um get input
function so where's the input coming
from so we built the model with the
features in it and now we need to go
ahead and create our get input function
this is the same as before but you'll
see
we now have it with the data set coming
in is going to be the same data set up
here and so if we scroll a little bit to
the right we should see the new and
there it is sure enough there's our new
on the right and so let's go ahead and
run that now we've defined our model we
defined where the information is coming
from and again you can go back and
review the first part because this is
identical that we did before except now
we have new as the column for the age
and we'll go ahead and do our model one
and let's go ahead and train it there's
our input function git input function
that we defined up here df train is
going to be the same and everything else
is going to be the same let's go ahead
and run that and it should go through
here and run the tensor info coming in
and it's going to go through in this
case where we have steps 1000 shuffling
so it's going to go randomly 128 per
batch
and then the epics is automatic we're
not worried about that today so now we
have a trained tensorflow model and with
our new model just like we did before we
want to go ahead and evaluate it so it's
the same setup we had before with our
same get input function with our df test
new in here coming in so there's our new
data coming in and this is really common
when you're doing these models you make
little tiny tweaks to see if you can
improve it one of the best articles i
read recently was you build your model
to fail you want a running model so you
actually have something to compare
against and then you continually tweak
it till you get a better accuracy now i
don't expect the accuracy necessarily to
get better on this
because of the way we partition the data
we can see here we now have an accuracy
of 0.76 which is a little bit over the
baseline and it's about what i would
have expected it to be kind of the same
the reason is because we split the data
at the 50 the people making over 50k and
those making less and so the age factor
shouldn't be a huge factor it would be
if we were looking at more discrete
buckets like 40 to 50 50 to 60 60 to 70
when we create buckets but in this i
didn't really expect it to go up that
much in fact we could probably run it a
dozen times which would be very bad data
science and we see we actually had a
slightly better one up here but our
baseline accuracy was 0.76 and we come
down here we still see
here's our accuracy baseline 0.763 that
didn't really change and you know the
accuracy didn't really go up that much i
could hit the run button a few times i
would probably upbeat the one above it's
not a big change but that's all right
that's how we learned is how we go
through and figure out what's going to
work with our data and what's not what's
going to improve the quality of our data
so we have a better prediction and
what's not and we can now go ahead and
utilize this model this is where it gets
exciting when you're actually working
with somebody or with your clients and
you come in and say okay here's my
predictions we're going to take a create
a list and we're going to use model 1
and we're going to predict and our input
function is get input function df test
new again this probably doesn't make too
big of a difference but we'll go ahead
and stick with the new data we created
number of epics 1 batch 128 so all this
should look pretty familiar but we're
running the prediction so we're going to
load all our predictions into the
predictions and let's go ahead and run
that and you'll see it go through the
tensorflow setup so it's running done
running local ops and then let's just go
ahead and print the df test new
ilocation zero so row 0 and we're going
to look at the predictions also for the
same location 0. let's go ahead and run
that and we can see here that we have
age 25 work class private
it has all the information coming in for
that individual and then it comes down
here we go ahead and get our
prediction and in this particular
instance there's our label zero uh and
then we come down here and we see it
takes a little bit for the setup to look
up but there's our array which also
returns a zero and it has information
for us on there probabilities logistics
on here so you can see there's all kinds
of additional information you can pull
from this and likewise we could do it
for position three let me go and run
that and what's kind of nice about this
is you can now see here's label one and
here's our logistics output and again if
they kind of hunt for a little bit in
this particular setup but here's the
output array and there's our one and
they match label one one so we predicted
for the very first one location zero
that it's going to be a zero on the
label it's going to make under 50 000
and the individual in two working class
private whatever set up on here capital
gain capital loss etc came up as one
meaning they're going to make over 50
000. so we covered a lot i mean this is
the basics and you can see as you dig
deeper when you look at some of this
code let me just go back up here we're
way back up here at the very top a
little too far overshot as you start
working in here we have one defining
your features and at this point we
didn't show this but i would probably
use either python or r to show a
relationship correlation because they
have some really easy packages in there
to pull that up so you can see what
features are really connected and how
they're connected uh and then we showed
you different features like we have ones
that are
integers and then we have ones like sex
that are objects you're zero one you're
male or female you're uh same thing with
race probably have just maybe 16
different races listed there ethnicities
things like that native country again
that's you don't have like infinite
number of native countries you just have
a handful so we look at this we have our
features we looked at that we have our
continuous features like age which is a
number or in this case an integer an
education number how many years and so
on along with your race your sex your
relationship which are just very
abbreviated uh categorical data uh so we
looked at that we went in there and we
showed you how to um where was it here
we go we go back up here so we create
our model the model knows what
categories are coming in that's really
important and this is probably the one
of the more complicated parts of this is
our input function and this input
function is so important so i want to
just re-hash the input function for that
reason uh this lets us know how we're
pulling the data it lets us know
if we're going to go through all the
data 20 times
or we're going to let the or we're just
going to let tensorflow itself keep
going until the training model reaches a
point that point is based on uh with
what they call bias you can become
biased on your training data and so when
it hits a certain point where it becomes
overly biased to just that data then it
doesn't really work really good in the
outside world you start losing keep it
generic but as close as possible to the
right answer so generic answers for a
huge amount of data and then we have our
batch size are we going to shuffle it
which we did and then also our estimator
inputs so you have your estimator
function here and then of course where
the actual data is coming from so you
can see all this is in that get input
function that's where a lot of the work
comes in putting this together and then
we train our model um that's pretty
straightforward once you have your input
function and all your setup training the
model is quick and then we go ahead and
evaluate and then we can go ahead and
create a predict and then you know look
at our predictions and how they work on
individuals so it's pretty it gives you
a whole roundabout setup on here and how
this is set up and how it's working
certainly there are um a lot more things
you can do with tensorflow this is the
basic tensorflow and it's always
developing so it's exciting this is
gonna be one of the most exciting fields
right now because it is really in an
infant stage and just exploding in the
market with that we have reached the end
of this complete tensorflow course i
hope you enjoyed this video do like and
share it thank you for watching and stay
tuned for more from simply learn
[Music]